FISCAL REVIEW AND BANKING AND
FINANCE INSTITUTIONS WILL COME
TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON. IN
RESPONSE THE CALL THE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCE EVEN FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL OF SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY- AT THIS POINT I
BELIEVE WE HAVE SENATOR BAIL ON
THAT HAS JOINED US WE MAY LATER
BE JOINED BY SENATORS HUESO HER
TITLE. LEYVA AND MCGUIRE THIRTY
BELL IF YOU HAVE STAFF MEMBERS
PRESENT CAN YOU PLEASE TELL US
WHO THAT IS. ALL RIGHT. WE ALSO
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE L. A.
OLD OFFICE THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT AND SUBJECT
MATTER PANELISTS. WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
ROOM PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE THEIR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO BEING. A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO UN MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON YOU BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING OUR I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU'RE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
CONSUME YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT'S DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW
AS WELL TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
PHONE NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS NINE EIGHT ONE. ZERO NINE
SEVEN NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES AND WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
THE- YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE
YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WE WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEDIAN SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
JUST INTO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL OF PATIENTS SO
THAT ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. WITH THAT. I WILL
EVERYONE TO THIS AFTERNOON'S
HEARING AND REMIND US THAT WE
WILL BE FOCUSING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
EXPANDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT. INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION. THIS PROPOSAL WAS
INITIALLY CONTAINED IN THE
GOVERNOR AND THE GOVERNOR
JANUARY PROPOSAL HOWEVER GIVEN
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
PROPOSAL AND THE LOSS OF OUR
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE SEASON DUE
TO- CALL THAT NINETEEN. IT WAS
DEFERRED IN JUNE IN ORDER TO
ALLOW MORE TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IT.
THIS INCLUDES HAVING HEARING
SUCH AS THIS ONE WE'RE HAVING
TODAY AND THE ASSEMBLY HAD ONE
LAST WEEK. I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
NOTE TATIAN PRIMARILY FOR THE
PUBLIC YOUR- AGENDAS MEMBERS
SHOULD REFLECT THE CORRECTION
IT WAS A CORRECTION THAT WAS
MADE. IN THE A HEARING AGENDA.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
ASK FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION INNOVATION
IS FOR TEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. AND FORTY FOUR
POSITIONS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET. AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION AND TWENTY
EIGHT POSITIONS IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION AND
EIGHTEEN STAFF POSITIONS IN THE
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE BUDGET
AND I'M GOING. THIS IS AN
OVERALL INCREASE OF NINETEEN
POINT TWO MILLION AND NINETY F.
T. E.'S BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND FULL-IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
DEPARTMENT. THIS IS A
CORRECTION FROM THE PREVIOUSLY
NOTED ASK OF FORTY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION AND NINETY
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS. AGAIN
MEMBERS THIS CORRECTED
INFORMATION IS ALREADY
REFLECTED IN THE AGENDAS THE
UPDATED AGENDAS THAT WERE SENT
TO YOUR OFFICE YESTERDAY. SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO ASK
OUR CULTURE FOR TODAY'S HEARING
SENATORS THE BRACKET IF YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE SOME OPENING
REMARKS SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I. THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE TODAY AND-
CONDUCTING- EARLIER BUDGET
HEARINGS I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
AMERICA FOR YOU. ON I'M A
PRETTY OF JOINT WITH OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
AND ON. ARM COMMITTEE ON
BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS I THINK IT'S-
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE GREAT.
BETTER CLARITY AS I SHOULD
STATE. I IT RELATES TO THE POLL
PROPOSED ON THE TRAILER BILL
BECAUSE IT'S- MANY QUESTIONS.
SINCE THE INTER OF THE OF THIS
MEASURE. OF WHY IS IT NECESSARY
AND WE NEED BETTER CLARITY
BECAUSE WE'RE ON AN IMPRESSION
THAT DVO ALREADY HOUSING
AUTHORITY. TO DO MUCH OF WHAT
HAS BEEN REQUESTED THAN THIS
TRAILER BILL SO SINCE THE LACK
OF- ALLEGED OPPORTUNITY HAVE
HEARINGS ON THIS WE APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO POSING SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS TO DIRECTOR ALVAREZ
TO COMMISSIONER ALVAREZ AS WELL
AS- OTHER PARTICIPANTS IN THIS.
ARE HEARING TODAY FROM YOU FOR
THE SUB. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
A CALLING WHAT WE'RE GOING DO
IS THE HEARING REALLY KIND OF
INTO TWO SECTIONS- WE WILL
FIRST HEAR ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. FROM OUR OUR USUAL
PARTICIPANTS L. A. L.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL
AS COMMISSIONER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT. THE SECOND SECTION
WILL HEAR TESTIMONY FROM-
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
BUREAU THE CALIFORNIA
REINVESTMENT COALITION. THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION A WITH
THAT WILL BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST
PRESENTER I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
OUR COMMISSIONER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF- BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT. COMMISSIONER MANUEL
ALVAREZ. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARES AND SENATORS.
MY NAME IS MANUAL ALVAREZ I AM
THE COMMISSIONER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT. PRIOR TO SOON
ASSUMING MY CURRENT ROLE I
SERVED IN A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT CAPACITIES WITHIN
CONSUMER FINANCIAL SERVICES.
INCLUDING A CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION ENFORCEMENT ATTORNEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AS WELL AS
WITH THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU. I'VE ALSO
SERVED AS GENERAL COUNSEL TO A
FINANCIAL TECHNOLOGY COMPANY.
SO I HAVE EXPERIENCED BOTH
ADVISING OPERATORS AND
ENTREPRENEURS ABOUT HOW TO
COMPLY WITH STATE AND FEDERAL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS. I ALSO
HAVE EXPERIENCE. PICKING UP THE
TELEPHONE AND TALKING TO
VICTIMS OF. FINANCIAL SCHEMES
AND CRIMES AND SO THE TOPIC OF
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
AND INNOVATION. IS VERY MUCH
NEAR AND DEAR TO ME. THANK YOU
ALL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION. WE APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO DISCUSS THIS ONCE
AGAIN WITH YOU SINCE THE LAST
HEARING IN MAY. IN JANUARY THE
GOVERNOR HIGHLIGHTED THE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA. TO
BETTER PROTECT ITS OWN
CONSUMERS. IT IS EVEN MORE
URGENT TODAY. LATE IN AUGUST.
WE KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZES THIS TO AS MANY OF
YOU HAVE BEEN LEADERS IN
CONSUMER PROTECTION ANY
KNOWLEDGE THIS PROPOSAL IS
CONTINGENT FUNDING IN THIS
YEAR'S STATE BUDGET PASSED IN
JUNE. PAT ACTORS IN THE
FINANCIAL INDUSTRY SPACE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO SEVERELY IMPAIR
CONSUMER'S LIFE. A DECEPTIVE
PRACTICE CAN MEAN YEARS OF DATA
OR RUINED CREDIT OR WORSE LOSS
OF THE HOME. WITH THE CAN NEVER
BEING ABLE TO REACH SOLVENCY.
THAT CAN AFFECT THE ABILITY TO
RENT AN APARTMENT FOR EXAMPLE
WHERE TO BUY A HOME. TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND CAN NEGATIVELY
AFFECT AN INDIVIDUAL'S MENTAL
HEALTH AND OVERALL WELL BEING.
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS DE
PRIORITIZED CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION EFFORTS. CLOSING
KEEPERS CONSUMER PROTECTION
EFFORTS AND SCUTTLING KEY RULES
THAT OFFERED INCREASED CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THEREBY LEAVING
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS VULNERABLE.
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT CALIFORNIA DESERVES THIS
IN ANY EVENT. AS THE LARGEST
STATE ECONOMY AND THE COUNTRY
IT IS WORTH CALIFORNIA TO HAVE
A FINANCIAL REGULATOR WITH
DIVERSE SET OF TOOLS AND
CAPABILITIES. SINCE THE ONSET
OF THE COVERT CHALLENGE THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT IS RECEIVED A 40%
INCREASE IN CALLS AND
COMPLAINTS FROM CONSUMERS.
THOSE ARE JUST THE CONSUMERS
WHO FIGURED OUT HOW TO FIND US.
AND WE'RE NOT EVEN THROUGH THE
WORST PART OF THE ECONOMIC
RECESSION. TO BE CLEAR THIS
PROPOSAL DOES NOT RE ORGANIZED
OR CREATE A NEW DEPARTMENT. THE
PARTS OF THE DEPARTMENT THAT
OPERATE TODAY WOULD CONTINUE TO
OPERATE THE PROPOSAL DOES. AND
IT ADDS TO THE DEPARTMENTS.
EXISTING KEEP. AND REGULATORY
FUNCTIONS. DODD FRANK VIBES
THAT STATE FINANCIAL REGULATORS
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE
PROVISIONS WITHIN DODD FRANK.
AGAINST UNFAIR DECEPTIVE AND
ABUSIVE ACTS AND PRACTICES.
THAT REQUIREMENT IS ALREADY
INCLUDED AND CONTEMPLATED BY
DODD FRANK THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
MAKE CLEAR AND EXPRESS DEVIDOS
AUTHORITY IN THIS AREA. BUT LET
ME STRESS THAT THESE
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT NEW AND
THE PENALTIES AND REMEDIES
CONTEMPLATED BY THE PROPOSAL.
ARE NOT NEW. I ALSO LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
THREE CONCERNS THAT SOME
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE RAISED ABOUT
THE PROPOSAL. FIRST WITH
RESPECT TO YOUR DATA OR THE
PROHIBITION ON UNFAIR DECEPTIVE
OR ABUSIVE ACTS AND PRACTICES.
AGAIN THIS IS NOT A NEW LEGAL
STANDARD. AND CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS OR SERVICES
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO DODD FRANK
SHOULD ALREADY BE COMPLYING
WITH THIS LAW AND THIS
EXPECTATION. SHOULD NOT BE
SCARY. THIS IS THERE IS NO
INTENTION TO PURSUE GOTCHA
OPPORTUNITIES. THIS MERELY
PROVIDES CONSUMERS ANOTHER
AVENUE FOR PROTECTION AND
REDRESS. SECOND EXISTING
LICENSEES HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW THESE NEW REQUIREMENTS
WOULD APPLY TO THEM WHEN THEY
HAVE AN EXISTING LICENSING
SCHEME. AGAIN THE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS UNDER DODD FRANK
HAS TO EXISTING STATE LICENSEES
IS NOT NEW. MANY IF NOT MOST OF
THEM HAVE ALREADY BEEN SUBJECT
TO THE FEDERAL YOU DOUBT
PROVISIONS AND EXPECTATIONS.
MOREOVER I AM HAPPY TO RELAY
THAT WE HAVE BEEN HAVING
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
EXISTING LICENSEES TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS. THIRD THERE
HAVE OF COURSE BEEN QUESTIONS
ABOUT LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. IT
HERE TOO I AM UP TO. THAT WE
CAN FIND AGREEMENT. WE HAVE
RECEIVED A PROPOSAL FROM
LEGISLATIVE STAFF WE HAVE WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
DISCUSSING MERITS WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND HAVING
REVIEWED THE PROPOSAL IN THE
LANGUAGE I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE
CAN REACH. A WORKABLE AGREEMENT.
THERE ARE SOME CONSUMER
FINANCIAL BUSINESSES THAT WILL
HARM CONSUMERS AND BENEFIT FROM
NO REGULATION OR VERY LIGHT
REGULATION. THOSE BUSINESSES
AND THOSE PRODUCTS WOULD COME
UNDER DEVIDOS UMBRELLA UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL. AND AS A RESULT
SOME OF COURSE WILL ALWAYS
REMAIN OPPOSED BECAUSE THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO MONITOR
PREVIOUSLY UNREGULATED
ACTIVITIES. WE NOW SKETCH OUT
IN BROAD BRUSHSTROKES. THE
PROPOSAL ITSELF. THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES RESOURCES FOR RESEARCH
GREATER COMMUNITY EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH IN AN OMBUDSPERSON
FUNCTION. AS WELL AS AN
INNOVATION TECHNOLOGY OFFICE
FOCUSED ON EMERGING AND
CHANGING FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES IN THE MARKETPLACE.
THE TRAILER BILL OUTLINES HOW
DEPARTMENTS EXPANDED OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY WOULD FUNCTION.
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT'S
REGULATION IS ROOTED IN
LICENSING STATUS WHEN A
CONSUMER HAS A COMPLAINT THE
FIRST QUESTION BUT THE
DEPARTMENT ASKS IS WHETHER THAT
BUSINESS HAS THE LICENSE FOR
SHOULD HAVE A LICENSE. IF THE
CONSUMER FINANCIAL BUSINESS
DOES NOT FALL SQUARELY WITHIN A
PRESCRIPTIVE DEFINITION IN
STATUTE. D. B. O. DOES NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION. OR ABILITY
FOREIGN FORTUNATE FORTY OVER
THAT ENTITY. AND DDO CANNOT ACT.
REGARD DECEPTIVE OR FAR TRY TO
PRACTICE BY A CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROVIDE IT IS NOT
LICENSED RADIO. EVEN IF ARE
BEING HARMED. THE TRAILER
PROVIDES FOR COMMISSION OF THE
NEED. THE REQUIRED CURRENT ON
MY FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES TO REGISTER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. EXAMPLES OF SUCH
CURRENTLY UNLICENSED PRODUCTS
OR SERVICES MIGHT INCLUDE. DEBT
COLLECTORS THAT RESOLUTION
SERVICE PROVIDERS CREDIT REPAIR
AGENCIES. FOR INCOME SHARE
PROVIDERS. THE DEPARTMENT THE
REGISTRATION WOULD BE ABLE TO
SUPERVISE THESE NEW COVERED
PERSONS TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH CONSUMER LAWS. YEAH THE
KERN DRAFT OF THE TREE BILL
WOULD OFFER THE TO ENFORCE TO
AT AS TO ALL THOSE THE
DEPARTMENT PURVIEW. CURRENT
LICENSE. IN WE INVEST A CAP
CONSUMERS PROTECT BY AN LEVEL
OF CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION. THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO ENFORCE
THESE LAWS IN THE LEARN
INFORMATION ABOUT CURRENTLY
UNREGULATED OR NEW INDUSTRIES
THROUGH THE REGISTRATION
PROCESS. ARMED WITH THAT
INFORMATION WE CAN OF COURSE
AND WHAT EXPECTED TO BETTER
PARTNER WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER AND HOW THE BEST
STRUCTURE FUTURE LICENSING
PROGRAMS. NOW LET ME TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW THE
PROPOSAL STRIVES TO BALANCE.
ACTION WITH INNOVATION. THE
PROPOSAL SEEKS TO BALANCE
CONSUMER PROTECTION ON THE ONE
HAND AND INNOVATION BY CREATING.
AND OF INNOVATION THAT WOULD
REPORT DIRECTLY INTO THE
COMMISSIONER. AND THAT OFFICES
MANDATE WOULD BE ESSENTIALLY TO
KEEP ITS FINGER ON THE PULSE OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN INNOVATION
IN FINANCIAL SERVICES. AND TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A HEALTHY
FEEDBACK LOOP THE- WHAT IS IN
THE MARKET PLACE WITH RESPECT
TO INNOVATION IN HOW THE
DEPARTMENT IS REACTING TO RAPID
CHANGES IN THE MARKET PLACE.
THE OBJECTIVE IS TO BRIDGE THE
GAP BETWEEN INNOVATION AND
REGULATORY ACTIVITIES SO THAT
EMERGING ACT IDEAS CAN BE
VETTED EARLY. AND THOROUGHLY.
AND THE REGULATORY HURDLES
COULD BE IDENTIFIED IN A
COLLABORATIVE ENVIRONMENT. THIS
WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS TO REAP THE BENEFITS.
OF NEW PRODUCTS AND NEW
TECHNOLOGIES WELL THE
DEPARTMENT WORKS IN THE
BACKGROUND TO HELP INSURE THAT
THESE PRODUCTS. ARE SAFE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. IN CONCLUSION I'D
AGAIN LIKE TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE AND LEGISLATIVE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US OVER THE
LAST EIGHT MONTHS. THE
LANGUAGES FIRST MADE PUBLIC IN
FEBRUARY. SINCE THEN WE'VE
TAKEN A VARIETY OF AMENDMENTS
ADDRESSING STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS.
FROM WORKING WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO WORKING WITH
BOTH ADVOCATES AND INDUSTRY TO
PROVIDE INCREASED CLARITY.
WE'VE COURSE HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE BEST
POSSIBLE PROPOSAL. CALIFORNIANS
JOYS TO WORLD CLASS ECONOMY.
AND WE BELIEVE IT DESERVES A
WORLD CLASS FINANCIAL
REGULATORY DEPARTMENT. AND
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN BUT NOT
THE FINAL ISSUES IN THE COMING
DAYS AND I WILL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
COMMISSIONER WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THOSE UNTIL WE HEAR FROM
THE OTHER TWO PANELISTS
REPRESENTING THE L. A. ON AND
FINANCE OUT NEXT MISS PETERS.
REPRESENTING THE ONLY HEALTH
OFFICE. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MR CO CHAIR SENATOR I JUST
COMPUTERS WITH ALLEGED. AND
OFFICE WE WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU TODAY SEVERAL ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
AROUND THIS PROPOSAL. AND
SPECIFICALLY ISSUES AROUND
POLICY ISSUES AS WELL AS SOME
FISCAL ISSUES AND UNCERTAINTY
AROUND THE FUNDING LEVEL OF
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE NEEDED.
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROPOSAL. SO
FIRST ON THE POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS I'M- THE
PROPOSAL WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO REGULATE MANY NEW
COVERED PERSONS. AND THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES ROUGHLY
THAT THIS TO BE ABOUT NINE
THOUSAND YOU COVERED PERSONS
ALTHOUGH THERE'S SOME
UNCERTAINTY. THAT NUMBER. AND
THAT THESE AT PERCENT OFFER
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS. I HAVE
ENDED UP. OF TO BE ABLE TO.
CERTAIN FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID.
AND OTHER. AS WE SPOKE TO BY
COMMISSION. I'M AND ONE THE
ADMINISTRATION INDICATES
OVERALL. OF THE PROPOSAL ARE
THIS AS JAN. OR THE- INITIAL OF
THE LINK. ON THE TRAILER
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN. AMEND IN
ACT TO LIMITS ASPECTS THE
PURPLE. AS WELL AS CLEAR THE
OVER PROPOSAL. AND THE SIGNET
DEGREE OF COMFORT. OF THIS
RIVER OVER ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. THE
PARK OVERSIGHT ANTI OF. SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE. AND SO FOR.
I AM WE THINK THE LOGISTICS SHE
CAN. IN THAT LED. PRIOR ARE.
HIM THAT THE PRO STRUCTURE ALL
TO FISTS. LEGISLATIVE. HOWEVER
THE LEGISLATURE HAS OPTIONS TO
INSURANCE PRIORITIES ARE MET.
I'M AND TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT AS WELL. ONE OPTION
COULD BE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
PUT MORE OF THE PROGRAM DETAILS
INTO STATUTE RATHER THAN
DEFERRING THIS ON THE DECISIONS
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
REGULAR. ACCESS ALTERNATIVELY
ALTERNATIVELY IN THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALLOW THE
ADMINISTRATION THE FLEXIBILITY
TO DEVELOP THESE PROGRAMS
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS
AS IT PROPOSES- BUT INSTEAD
ESTABLISH MORE OF A BACK END
TYPE OF OVERSIGHT OF ONGOING
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
PROCESS. SUCH AS HAVING THE NEW
REGULATORY AUTHORITY SUNSET
AFTER A PERIOD OF TIME IN ORDER
TO ALLOW LEGISLATIVE REVIEW ON
AN ASSESSMENT OF OUTCOMES TO
DETERMINE WHETHER SUCH A
PROGRAM SHOULD CONTINUE. OR IF
CHANGE SHOULD BE. I'M IN THE
EVALUATION THESE POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS LEGISLATURE ALSO
WANT TO BALANCE THE TIME NEEDED
TO DEVELOP. A DETAILED PROPOSAL
WITH THE DESIRE TO QUICKLY
ESTABLISH CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
I'M GIVEN THAT COMPLEXITY OF
THE PROPOSAL AND THAT THE CODE
PANDEMIC HAS TRUNCATED THE
USUAL BUDGET AND POLICY
PROCESSES. THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER TAKING
MORE TIME TO EVALUATE AND WEIGH
IN ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
PROGRAMS AND STATE
RESPONSIBILITIES. I'M IN
PARTICULAR IF THE LEGISLATURE
DECIDES TO GO THE ROUTE OF
PUTTING MORE OF THIS
INFORMATION INTO STATE LAW
RATHER THAN DEFERRING THE
DECISIONS TO THE REGULATORY
PROCESS. I'M IN THE LEGISLATURE
WORD WHAT MORE TIME YOU COULD
CONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL AND THE
NEXT I JUST IT SESSION. AND IT
COULD NOT CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ADMINISTRATION ON REFINING THE
PROPOSAL IN THE MEANTIME. I IN
THE THIRD POLICY CONSIDERATION
IS TO CONSIDER THE STATE VERSUS
FEDERAL. I'M SORRYKEY
JUSTIFICATION PROVIDED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS
PROPOSAL IS THAT WOULD ALLOW
THE STATE TO FILL A REGULATORY
ROLE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS TAKEN A STEP
BACK FROM IMPLEMENTING BY IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT FUTURE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS COULD TAKE A
MORE PROACTIVE ROLE. IN
ENFORCING FEDERAL FINANCIAL
REGULATIONS AND SO THIS COULD
RAISE THE QUESTION OF HOW MUCH
ADDITIONAL VALUE IS BEING ADDED
FOR THE STATE'S UPPER ON TOP OF
FEDERAL EFFORTS. NOW THE SECOND
SET OF CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE
WANT TO RAISE FOR YOU RELATE TO
THE FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM. AS
HAS BEEN INDICATED THE TRAILER
LEGISLATION HAS. BEEN AMENDED
IT VERY SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSED VERSION.
HOWEVER THE MINISTRATION HAS
NOT PROVIDED AN UPDATED
ESTIMATE OF THE FUNDING NEEDED.
TIME TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM
THAT WOULD ALIGN WITH THE-
ACTUAL TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT'S BEING PUT FORWARD-
TODAY. AND SO WE THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
CONSIDER THREE STOPS WHEN
DETERMINING THE FUNDING IT
PROVIDES. IF THERE IS AN
AGREEMENT REACHED ON THE
TRAILER LEGISLATION. THE FIRST
I'M IS SCALING THE FUNDING TO
THE FINAL TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND THEY JUST SAID THAT-
PROPOSED FINDING AND THAT THE
TIME ADMINISTRATION BELIEVED TO
BE NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
LANGUAGE. HASN'T BEEN REALIGNED
THE NEW VERSION OF THE LANGUAGE
AND THERE COULD BE ADDITIONAL
CHANGES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN THE
LANGUAGE I'M BEFORE A FINAL
AGREEMENT IS REACHED. AND SO
THE FINAL LANGUAGE WE THINK
SHOULD JUST SCALE AND ALIGN
WITH WHAT'S ACTUALLY IN THE
AGREED UPON TIME TRAILER
LEGISLATION. SECOND WE THINK IT
WOULD BE WISE TO NOT COMMIT TO
FUTURE FUNDING INCREASES. AT
THIS TIME- ASISTIR NOTED IN
YOUR STOPPAGE AND THAT THERE'S
I'M OUT YOUR INCREASES TO THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING. IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THIS
ONE'S ACTUALLY BEEN SET ASIDE
AND AS PART OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET PAN. AND ARE
RESPONSIBLE TO THE MINISTRATION
THROUGH EIGHT- JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
PROCESS- IN ORDER TO ACCESS
THOSE FINES. AND THAT BUT WE
THINK THAT NOT COMMITTING TO
THE FUTURE OUT YOUR INCREASES
OF THOSE TIMES WOULD BE
PRUDENT. HI I'M THIS IS BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
AROUND WITH THOSE OUT YOUR
COSTS WILL ACTUALLY BE. I'M FOR
EXAMPLE THERE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES IT WILL COVER ABOUT
NINE THOUSAND NEW COVERED
PERSONS OFFER FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS OR SERVICES- BUT
BECAUSE THIS PROPOSAL REGULATE
I CURRENTLY I'M REGULATED
COMMUNITY. THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF
COVERED PERSONS AND COULD
DIFFER SIGNIFICANTLY. I'M AND
SECOND HAS NOTED. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
DIFFERS A LOT OF THE DETAILS OF
HOW THE PROGRAM SHOULD ACTUALLY
BE IMPLEMENTED. TO THE
REGULATORY PROCESS AND THE
WORKLOAD THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
ASSOCIATED WITH IMPLEMENTING
THESE NEW PROGRAMS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES WON'T BE KNOWN
UNTIL THOSE REGULATIONS HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPED. AND THREE
DIFFERING ANY DECISIONS ON HOW.
YOUR WORKLOAD I'M WOULD BE
PRUDENT. I AND THEN LAST YOU
MAY WANT TO CAN IN WITH PENDING
LET IN PARTICULAR NINE OH EIGHT
BY. RIGHT HOUSE SKI WEIGHED AND
SIGNIFICANTLY OVERLAP WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. AND THAT BILL
REQUIRES A LICENSURE PROGRAM
FOR DEBT COLLECTORS WHERE ADDS
THE TRAILER BILL PROPOSAL
REQUIRES A REGISTRATION PROGRAM
FOR DEBT COLLECTORS. I HAVE A
WE SHOULD BE TWO DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AS SORT OF A LICENSURE
PROGRAM BEING- A MORE ROBUST
REGULATORY PROGRAM AND SO IT
MIGHT NOT MAKE SENSE TO PROVIDE
FUNDING. AND DVO OR THE NEW
DEPARTMENT TO- START STANDING
UP A REGISTRATION PROGRAM IF
THE LEGISLATURE IS ALSO GOING
TO PASS LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
CHANGE THAT INTO A FULL
LICENSURE PROGRAM- AND WE WOULD
JUST NOW AND THAT AS IS THE
TYPICAL PROCESS WITH ANY NEW
LEGISLATION- THAT. THE FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DUCT.
COLLECTOR PIECE COULD BE.
THROUGH THE NEXT BUDGET THROUGH
A BUDGET PROPOSED AS IS TYPICAL.
I'M WITHOUT HAPPY DANCE ANY
QUESTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO HEAR
DIRECTLY FROM THE PARTMINER
FINANCE AND THEN WE'LL OPEN IT
UP- BLACKS ARE GOING TO OPEN IT
UP AFTER- THE PANEL LIKE WE DID
IN THE LAST SESSION. SO LET'S
HEAR FROM THIS HARBISON WITH-
FINANCES HARBISON. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
CHAIRS AND SENATORS. AND CAN
REALLY HARBISON FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YEAH
SURELY MANNING IS ALSO HERE
WITH US REMOTELY TODAY I WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO COMMISSIONER
ALVAREZ'S GRATITUDE FOR
PROVIDING US. THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS THIS PROPOSAL WITH
YOU TODAY I WOULD ALSO
ESPECIALLY LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF FOR THEIR
TIME AND FEEDBACK AS THEY WORK
WITH US TO REFINE AND IMPROVE
THIS PROPOSAL. OVER MANY MONTHS
AND THAT'S VERY UNUSUAL YEAR.
I'M AS YOU KNOWN AS THE ELLIE-
JUST MENTIONED THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT INCLUDES
FUNDING IN A SET ASIDE ITEM.
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
LEVELS THAT WE PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BZP. THE
FUNDING IS INCLUDED IN OVERALL
BUDGET TOTALS BUT IS NOT YET
AVAILABLE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT. IS
CONTINGENT UPON THE LEGISLATORS
APPROVAL AND THE GOVERNOR
SIGNATURE OF THE RELATED
LANGUAGE. WAS SUBSEQUENT NODES
NOTIFICATION TO THE JAIL BC.
I'D LIKE TO NOTE THIS IS NOT A
GENERAL FUND REQUEST AN
EXISTING LICENSEES ARE NOT
EXPECTED TO PAY ANY OF THE COST
FOR THIS PROPOSAL. THE COST OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION LAW
PROGRAM WILL BE COVERED BY NEW
COVERED PERSON REGISTRATION
FEES. EXISTING ACCUMULATED
SETTLEMENT REVENUES AND
EVENTUALLY NEW SETTLEMENT
REVENUES SENATOR MITCHELL THANK
YOU FOR ANNOUNCING THE
CORRECTIVE BUDGET REQUEST
AMOUNT AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
HEARING AND I'D LIKE TO
REITERATE THAT. THE NUMBERS
JUST IN CASE ANYONE HAS TUNED
IN LATE. SO IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE REQUESTED FOR TEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS AND FORTY
FOUR POSITIONS. IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THE REQUESTED
FOURTEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION.
AND AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY EIGHT
POSITIONS SO THAT'S AN INCREASE
OF FOUR POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THE TOTAL AMOUNT IS
NINETEEN POINT THREE POSITIONS.
AND IT'S AN ADDITIONAL EIGHTEEN
POSITIONS. SO I HAVE FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
AND THAT BRINGS THE TOTAL O
ALL POSITIONS TO DO NINETY. IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR NOT
GOING THERE'S A SLIGHT DIP OF
ABOUT A HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ONCE ALL THE
HIRING HAS BEEN COMPLETED THOSE
ONE TIME COSTS DROP OFF. THESE
AMOUNTS REFLECT A 15% INCREASE
IN POSITIONS THAT FULL
IMPLEMENTATION. AND A SEVENTEEN
POINT 5% INCREASE IN BUDGETARY
EXPENDITURES. NOT A 41%
BUDGETARY INCREASE AS WAS
POSTED IN THE FIRST VERSION OF
THE AGENDA. AND WE ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE SENATE BUDGET STAFFER
PUBLISHING THE CORRECTION. THIS
IS A HIGH PRIORITY PROPOSAL FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION- WE KNOW
THAT IN DIFFICULT ECONOMIC
TIMES SUCH AS THE ONE THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY IN. BAD ACTORS
OFTEN PREY ON THOSE IN
FINANCIAL DISTRESS. THIS THOSE
MOST PROPORTIONATE. SR THOSE
MOST DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED INCLUDE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. YOUR CALIFORNIANS THOSE
IN UNDER RESOURCED COMMUNITIES
AND SENIORS.WE ARE SEEKING
YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN PROVIDING
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO THESE
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS.
BY AUTHORIZING RESOURCING THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO THIS CRITICAL
WORK. WE THINK THERE'S A PATH
FORWARD ON THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT AN EXISTING LICENSEE
ISSUES. AND WE WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WITH LEGISLATIVE STAFF
AND STAKEHOLDERS. OVER THE
WEEKEND AND INTO EARLY NEXT
WEEK TO RESOLVE THESE LAST TWO
COMPONENTS OF THE PROPOSAL. TO
ACHIEVE HE CONSUMER PROTECTION
THE ADMINISTRATION IS SEEKING
TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTING NOW. AND
THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS HARBISON- BUT WHAT I
THINK. IS PROBABLY MORE PRUDENT
COLLEAGUES ALL OPEN UP FOR
QUESTIONS NOW OF THE
COMMISSIONER FINANCE AND L.
I'LL BE STARTING WITH THE CHAIR
OF BANKING THAN GOING TO OTHER
MEMBERS- AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
TESTIMONY FROM THE PANEL BUT I
WANTED YOU TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. TARGET YOUR
QUESTIONS- AT THIS POINT TO THE
COMMISSIONER ELLIE ON FINANCE
WITH THAT SENATOR BRADLEY WILL
START WITH YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I HAVE THREE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS FOR. COMMISSIONER
ALVAREZ AND I APPRECIATE HIS
PRESENTATION BUT I'M- LOOKING
VIEWS- DOESN'T DODD FRANK
ALREADY GIVE THE DEPARTMENT
AUTHORITY TO BRING. ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS AGAINST EXISTING
LICENSEES ENGAGED. AND THE
UNFAIR DECEPTIVE AND ABUSIVE
PRACTICES. THANK YOU SENATOR
YES DODD FRANK CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZES CONTEMPLATES AN
AUTHORIZES. STATE BANKING
DEPARTMENTS TO PURSUE THOSE
THOSE REMEDIES AS TO AS TO
CURRENTLY LICENSED ENTITIES.
OKAY AND DODD FRANK'S BEEN IN
EXISTENCE TO. BEEN IN EXISTENCE
SINCE- TWO THOUSAND AND TEN.
AND TO THE BEST OF YOUR
KNOWLEDGE SHOWS DVO OR YOUR
PREDECESSOR DEPARTMENTS
DEPARTMENT CORPORATIONS ARE OF.
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS EVER
BROUGHT ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
AGAINST ONE OF THE LICENSEES.
USED THE DOOR PROVIDE. VIA DOT.
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE CENTER OKAY.
SO AM I UNDERSTANDING YOU JUST
SIMPLY ADDING LANGUAGE TO
EXISTING LAW TO GIVE YOU THE
AUTHORITY THAT YOU ALREADY OUT
BUT NEVER USE IT. CORRECT THE
OBJECTIVE IS TO CLARIFY WHAT
WOULD OTHER WHAT COULD
OTHERWISE BE A CONFUSING
PATCHWORK. SO THAT WE MORE
CLEARLY HAVE A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD IN STATE LAW. SO MY FINAL
QUESTION SO. THIS TRAILER BILL
SIMPLY RESTATES THE UW BOARDED
OFFERINGS GIVE YOU OVER YOUR
LICENSEES. OR WOULD YOU SAY
THAT THE TRAILER BILL TRIES TO
ADD SOME LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY
THE AUTHORITY OR EXPAND UPON IT.
WITHRESPECT TO EXISTING
LICENSEES I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
THE- I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THE
OBJECTIVE IS TO- EXPANDED THE
AUTHORITY EXPAND OR OTHERWISE A
BRIDGE THE AUTHORITIES- GIVEN
BY FEDERAL LAW. WHAT IT WOULD
AGAIN STRIVE TO DO IS TO IMPOSE
A LEVEL FIELD WRIST TO
LICENSEES AS WELL AS THOSE
ENTITIES ARE CURRENTLY
UNREGULATED OR LIGHTLY
REGULATED SO THE OBJECTIVE IS.
CLARITY ACROSS THE BOARD AND
STRIVING TOWARD A MORE LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD. OKAY WELL I'M
GOING TO I'M FAMILIAR WITH ANY
OF YOUR LICENSEES OF EVER
STATED THAT YOU DON'T CURRENTLY
HAVE THAT AUTHORITY UNDER DODD
FRANK SO I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. THE NECESSITY HERE
OF THIS TRAILER BILL. ANY
COMMENTS FROM HELLO. ON THAT
POINT OR FINANCE. OKAY SCENE IS
THAT IT SENATOR BRADFORD. THE
MORE BUT I CAN NOT. ALL RIGHT.
AND ONE OTHER QUESTION I CAN
YOU GIVE ME AN UPDATE ON THE
PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING CONCERNS
FROM THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE
LACK OF LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
BUILT. INTO YOUR PROPOSAL. YES
CENTER WE HAVE- LAST- THE LAST
UPDATE I RECEIVED THE
DEPARTMENTS HAS RECEIVED
PROPOSED LANGUAGE FROM SENATE
SUCH AN ASSEMBLY STAFF- WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF DISCUSSING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION.
CONSIDERING THE MERITS AS WELL
AS THINKING THROUGH HOW BEST TO
OPERATIONALIZE. SOME OF THE-
SOME OF THE PROPOSALS- PROVIDED
BY LEGISLATIVE STAFF- SO WELL I
CANNOT COMMIT TO- ANYTHING-
TODAY- BECAUSE WE ARE WE'RE
STILL DISCUSSIN WITH WITH
ADMINISTRATION AND LEADERSHIP
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION- I
CAN SAY THAT HAVING HAVING
LOOKED AT THE PROPOSAL AND
HAVING THOUGHT ABOUT. ITS
IMPLEMENTATION I AM- I'M
CONFIDENT I'M I'M FAIRLY
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE CAN FIND A
PATH FORWARD. AND MY FINAL
QUESTION WHAT MILESTONES ARE
RESULT SURE WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
BE ABLE TO MEASURE OUR SUCCESS
HERE. CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
MILESTONES. WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT THE THREE YEAR
PROGRESSION AND TERMS OF THE
FOLLOWING HIGH LEVEL MILESTONES
YEAR ONE- WE WOULD OF COURSE
NEED TO START BY. BUILDING OUT
THE NEW THE NEW DIVISIONS AND
THEN YOU FUNCTIONS BY HIRING
KEY LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AS
WELL AS START STARTING TO BUILD
OUT THE SKELETON STRUCTURE OF
EACH NEW FUNCTIONS SUCH AS THE
NEW COVERED PERSONS DIVISION AS
WELL AS MARKET MONITORING
FUNCTIONS. WE WOULD OF COURSE
START TO SPIN OUT OF THE OFFICE
OF FINANCIAL TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION IN YEAR ONE AND SIX
IN ENGAGEMENT SHORTLY
THEREAFTER IN ADDITION
STAKEHOLDERS. AND WE WOULD-
LOOK AT TAKING NEW CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS REGARDING NEW
COVERED PERSONS AND START TO
DEVELOP. A SENSE OF THAT MARKET
PLACE SO YEAR ONE IS ABOUT
STARTING TO BUILD OUT
LEADERSHIP THE SKELETON OF THE
STRUCTURE. AND STARTING TO GET-
A BETTER SENSE OF THE LAY OF
THE LAND YOUR TO WOULD BE
FOCUSED ON COMMENCING-
COMMENCING WITH REGULATIONS
WHERE WHERE WARRANTED AND
APPROPRIATE- WE WOULD ALSO SEEK
TO SPEND UP THE EDUCATION
OFFICE AND ADDITIONAL OUTREACH
TO PARTICULAR POPULATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUCH AS NEW
CALIFORNIANS. SENIORS AS WELL
AS- STUDENTS. S. CONTINUE
HIRING POSITIONS INTO THE
SECOND YEAR AND WE WOULD EXPECT
TO BEGIN- THE VISITATION WITH
RESPECT TO NEW COVER PERSONS.
UNDER UNDER A NEW REGISTRATION
PROCESS. YOUR THREE WOULD BE
ALL ABOUT FINALIZING
REGULATIONS- WHERE WARRANTED
AND FULLY IMPLEMENTING THE
REGISTRATION PROCESS. AND
CLOSING OUT CLOSER OUT
REMAINING HIRING NEEDS SO TO
READ YOUR ONES ABOUT. TILTING
UP THE SKELETON STRUCTURE
STARTING TO UNDERSTAND THE
NEARLY OF THE LAND HERE TO USE
IMPLEMENTATION WITH NEW
REGULATIONS AND INCREASING
VISITATION OF NEW COVERED
PERSONS IN YOUR THREE IS ABOUT
WRAPPING UP WRAPPING UP THAT-
AND THAT THREE YEAR BUILD
PERIOD. MISTER AND I WOULD JUST
CONCLUDE ON I'M VERY SUPPORT OF
A PORTIONS OF- THIS PROPOSAL
THE GIVE YOU AUTHORITY AS IT
RELATES TO THE UNLICENSED
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND SERVICES
BUT I AM REALLY CONCERNED AND I
THINK THIS JUST ADDS A NEW
AUTHORITY AND I DON'T SEE WHAT
PROBLEM EXISTS RIGHT NOW WITH
YOUR CURRENT LICENSEES THAT
JUSTIFIES THIS. ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE CHAIRMAN BRADFORD WILL
MOVE ON TO SENATOR ROTH WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MADAM THANK YOU
MANAGER AND GIVE MY MIKE THIS
FELLA. YOU KNOW I'M- I'M ALWAYS
CONCERNED WHEN WE PROPOSED TO
ADD NEW GOVERNMENT. AT A TIME
WHEN WE HAVE A FAIRLY
SUBSTANTIAL AND SIGNIFICANT
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. IN OUR
STATE THAT THE- FRANKLY-
FAILING IN NEED SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF HELP BOTH IN TERMS
OF THE TIME AND ATTENTION. OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE TIME
AND ATTENTION OF THIS
LEGISLATURE. AND THE- AND
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING ONGOING AND
ADDED PROBABLY AS PART OF OUR
BUDGET. BUT I TRIED TO AFTER I
SPOKE TO FOLKS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE YESTERDAY I TRIED
LAST NIGHT TO GET MY HANDS
AROUND IT AND WHAT'S-
FRUSTRATING FOR ME IS THE LACK
OF WRITTEN MATERIAL SINCE I DO
READ OCCASIONALLY. TO DESCRIBE
THE DETAIL OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
MORE PARTICULARLY THE URGENCY
AND THE SPECIFIC NEED NOW. FOR
US TO BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE DOING
AND TO TAKE TIME TO. TO PROCESS
THIS. THROUGH THIS HOUSE AND SO
I GUESS MY FIRST QUESTION SINCE
THEY DID TEACH ME I THINK YOU
OUGHT TO ASK THEM. IS DID WE DO
A NEEDS ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE.
EXACTLY OR APPROXIMATELY HOW
MANY COMPLAINTS AND ENFORCEMENT
CASES. DROPPED THROUGH THE
CRACKS SINCE THE REDUCED
FUNDING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL OF
THE FEDERAL CFPB. ACTIVITIES IN
THE APPARENT INABILITY OR
UNWILLINGNESS OF OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND R. FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S TO.
PICK UP THE SLACK CAN CONDUCT
THESE ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES.
THANK YOU SENATOR I AM NOT. OF
THE NEEDS ASSESSMENT OF ANY
NEEDS ASSESSMENT CONDUCTED- AT
THE STATE LEVEL. THAT ACTUALLY
POINTS TO ONE OF THE IN MY VIEW
ONE OF THE CRITICAL PIECES OF
THE PROPOSAL WHICH IS BROADLY
SPEAKING THE TO TELL TOP A
ROBUST MARKET MONITORING
FUNCTION. AS A DEPARTMENT IS
GOOD EXISTS TODAY WE DO NOT
HAVE A GREAT MARKET MONITORING
FUNCTION- WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
GREAT CAPABILITIES WITH RESPECT
TO- REACHING OUT INTO THE BROAD
MARKET PLACE IN UNDERSTANDING-
UNDERSTANDING OF THE MACRO
LANDSCAPE OR THE IMPLICATIONS
OF- ECONOMIC SHOCKS SUCH AS THE
ONE THAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH
RIGHT NOW SO- I THINK YOUR
QUESTION IS. WELL RECEIVED AND
YOU KNOW MY VIEW POINTS TO SOME
OF THE NEEDS THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE FOR MORE ROBUST BUSINESS
INTELLIGENCE MARKET MONITORING
TYPE FUNCTIONS. WELL LET ME LET
ME TRY TO ASK IT ANOTHER WAY I
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE. YOU
MENTIONED THE VIN OF 40% AND IN
COMPLAIN THAT. HAS ASIDE EXPERT
OR WITH A RECEIVED. WITH
RESPECT TO THOSE COMPLAINTS
HOWEVER THOSE COMPLAINTS
DISTRIBUTED WITH REGARD TO
THOSE ENTITIES THAT YOU
CURRENTLY CURRENTLY LICENSE AND
KNOWS. NEWLY FOR POTENTIAL
NEWLY COVERED PERSONS I THINK
THAT'S HOW WE DESCRIBE IT I
WOULD CALL THEM POTENTIAL.
LICENSEES OF REGISTRANTS. WARS
OR SOMETHING ELSE. THANK YOU
SENATOR THE DISTRIBUTION OF THE
OF THE INCREASE OF COMPLIANCE
IS ACTUALLY FAIRLY. EARLY
SCATTERED- WE'VE BEEN- WE'VE
WE'VE DONE NOT A DEEPER DIVE
ASATRU CAUSING HOUSES OF THE
COMPLAINTS THAT COME IN AND- D.
THAT THE THRUST OF THE
COMPLAINTS IS REALLY ALL OVER
THE PLACE RANGING FROM-
ACTIVITIES THAT WE CURRENTLY
TOUCHES SUCH AS- MORTGAGE
LENDING OR TRANSMISSION OF
MONEY- AS WELL AS- VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES THAT OU WE DON'T
REALLY. ACTIVITIES ARE
COMPANIES THAT WE DON'T.
CURRENTLY TOUCH- FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE POTENTIALLY THE NEGOTIATION
OF THAT WERE PROMISES MADE WITH
RESPECT TO- CREDIT
RESTRUCTURING THINGS OF THAT
NATURE- THERE ARE ALSO OF
COURSE A SMATTERING OF
COMPLAINTS RELATED TO-
INCLUDING EXCUSE ME ALLEGATIONS
OF OUTRIGHT FRAUD FOR EXAMPLE.
IN THE OFFERING OF. THE
SECURITIES AND- WITH RESPECT TO
THOSE YOU KNOW THE ANSWER IS.
THE ANSWER DEPENDS ON THE TYPE
OF SECURITY AN ALLEGATION AND
AN ALL ALL THINGS OF THAT
NATURE BUT THE UPSHOT IS THAT.
LEAVE THE INCREASING INCOME
HAVE BEEN ALL OVER THE PLACE
THERE'S THERE HASN'T BEEN-
GREAT AMOUNT OF RHYME OR REASON
TO THEM- EXCEPT TO SAY THAT
THAT THE VOLUME OF COMPLAINTS
HAS BEEN INCREASING OVER TIME.
WELL I MEAN SECURITY SOME OF
THAT'S SEC ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
I REALIZE THE STATE HAS
POTENTIALLY SOME REAL I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE-
WHAT THE RATIONALE AND THE
REASON FOR THIS IS AND THAT'S
WHY I GUESS MY QUESTION ABOUT
THE 40% INCREASE IN COMPLAINTS.
WELL LET ME TRY TO DRILL DOWN A
LITTLE BIT MORE HAVE ANY OF THE
ISSUES. HAVE THERE BEEN ANY
ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO THE
CURRENT LICENSEES THE DPO.
CANNOT AND HAS NOT. BEEN
HANDLING IN THE NORMAL COURSE
OF BUSINESS. HERE. THIS THIS
THIS GETS INTO- POTENTIALLY
CONVERSATIONS AROUND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITY- WHAT I
CAN SAY BROADLY IS THAT. THERE
HAVEN'T BEEN- I WOULD SAY THERE
HAVEN'T BEEN MARKET CONCERNS
WITH RESPECT TO ACTIVITIES
HAPPENING AT THE CURRENTLY
LICENSE EVEN THIS LICENSE TO
LEVELS- I THINK THE BROADER
CONCERN IS WHAT TO DO ABOUT-THOSE THOSE AREAS THAT WE
CURRENTLY ARE UNABLE TO TOUCH.
WELL THAT'S THAT LEADS TO MY
NEXT QUESTION THEN WHY NOT JUST
FOCUS ON THE CURRENTLY
UNLICENSED OR UNREGISTERED
ENTITIES OF. PERHAPS THAT WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE SIZE
OF THE BUDGET REQUEST IN THE-
SIZE OF THE GOVERNMENT. AGENCY
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED WOULD
REORGANIZE AGENCY THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED. THANK YOU SENATOR I
WOULD SUBMIT THAT AB DE THOSE
SORTS OF INCREMENTAL CHANGES TO
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
PROBABLY DO NOT MARKEDLY CHANGE
THE RESOURCE REQUEST- CURRENTLY
PENDING- BUT IT DEFINITELY I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT. TO
RECOGNIZE THAT PART OF WHAT THE
PROPOSAL SEEKS TO ATTAIN IS A
MORE LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WHICH
IS- WHICH IS OF COURSE GOOD FOR
CONSUMERS AS AS WELL AS THE
MARKET PLACE- THE OBJECTIVE IS
TO MINIMIZE CONFUSION IN THE
MARKETPLACE THROUGH- A PASSWORD
INTO AS BEST AS POSSIBLE AND
WITHIN THE STRUCTURE OF
EXISTING LICENSING REGIMES-
APPLY AND APPLY THE LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD- SOMETHING
RESEMBLING PARITY. WELL YOU
KNOW I I'M I'M TRYING TO I'M
NOT AN ACCOUNTANT IT LOOKS TO
ME LIKE THE- RUBIO HAS A-
SPECIAL FUND CONDITION AND- IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF A HUNDRED
AND FORTY MILLION DOLLARS SOME
OF WHICH WERE GOING TO USE I
GUESS TO STAND UP THIS. THIS
ENTITY AND I ASSUME THAT
SPECIAL FUND WAS NOT SWEPT IS
PART OF OUR- SEARCH FOR BUDGET
MONEY IN THE LATEST. BUDGET
ROUND WHERE WE WERE. SLEEPING
JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING ELSE
INCLUDING THE FLOOR TO FIND
MONEY THAT ABOUT CORRECT. SURE
ISN'T AS FAR AS I'M AWARE
SENATOR YES SO IT IT IT IT DOES
SOUND TO ME A BIT LIKE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT STANDING UP
SKELETONS CONSTRUCTORS AND-
CREATING MARKET REVIEW- OFFICES
TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE IS ANY. NEED FOR THE
ORGANIZATION AND ANY ANY ANY.
CONSULT NEED IN TERMS OF
COMPLAINTS THAT WE'RE PUTTING
THE CART BEFORE THE HORSE HERE
WAS THERE ANY SORT OF-
GOVERNMENT REORGANIZATION PLAN
OR IF WE DON'T WANT TO CALL IT
THAT ANY SORT OF WRITTEN
REORGANIZATION PLAN THAT WAS
THOUGHT THROUGH AND PREPARED
AND REDUCE TO WRITING WITH
RESPECT TO THIS. RATHER
DRAMATIC CHANGE IN THE WAY WE
DO BUSINESS WITH RESPECT TO
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT AND THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT WE TAKE
INTO OUR OVERSIGHT- PURVIEW.
THANK YOU SENATOR I'M HAPPY TO
DISCUSS THE- THE PROCESS IN THE
RATIONALE THAT WENT INTO
DEVELOPING THE RESOURCE
REQUESTS SELF- THE SHORT ANSWER
IS. YES WE- WE UNDERTOOK A
PROCESS AND OF COURSE THESE
WERE THESE WERE PROJECTIONS BUT
THEY WERE INFORMED PROJECTIONS.
BASED ON AVAILABLE INFORMATION.
ABOUT WHAT THE UNIVERSE- WITH
POTENTIALLY NEW COVERED PERSONS
WILL LOOK LIKE IN THAT REGARD
WE LOOK DOWN EVERYTHING FROM.
DATA DATA PROVIDED BY THE C. F.
P. B. WE RELIED ON
CONVERSATIONS AND DATA FROM
TRADE GROUPS AS WELL AS OTHER
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE SOURCES OF
INFORMATION TO MAKE AN INFORMED
ASSESSMENT ABOUT WHAT THE
POTENTIAL UNIVERSE LOOKS LIKE
USING NOT. USING THAT. SURE
THAT PROJECTION LOANS- WE THEN
RELIED ON THE IN LEADERSHIP
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT TODAY AND
HOUSE QUESTION. GIVEN HOW WE
CURRENTLY STAFFS IN RESOURCE
OUR ACTIVITIES HOW WOULD WE
RESOURCE THEIR DANCE THAT THIS
PROJECTED NEED SO I WOULD
SUBMIT THAT THERE WAS A AND
THERE WAS A PROCESS AND I THINK
IT WAS A SENSIBLE AND WELL
INFORMED PROCESS- BUT- YOU ARE
CORRECT AT THE END OF THE DAY
THIS IS THAT THIS THIS IS AN
INFORMED PROJECTION- THAT WILL.
CONTINUE TO BE PERFORMED IN
REVISED AS WE LEARN TO GET
SMARTER ONE WHAT'S CONCERT TO
ME IS THERE DOESN'T APPEAR TO
BE A WRITTEN DOCUMENT AND
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU. WHEN YOU
DEBATE THESE ISSUES INTERNALLY
IN AN ORGANIZATION I'M OLD
ENOUGH TO HAVE BEEN IN A FEW OF
THEM- FRICTION WITNESSES COME
OUT YOU IDENTIFY HOLES. TO PLUG
HOLES YOU FIGURE OUT. WORST
CASE SCENARIO AND YOU FOR AND
YOU REDUCE IT TO WRITING. AND
IT DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE THAT
SORT OF THOUGHTFUL AND I'M NOT
SAYING IT WASN'T THOUGHTFUL
BUT- IT WASN'T THOUGHTFUL IN
THE SENSE THAT THERE WAS A
WRITTEN PRODUCT THAT WAS
PRODUCED THAT THAT WE IS A
LEGISLATURE. COULD REVIEW TO
UNDERSTAND THE THOUGHT PROCESS
AND THE NOT THE ANALYSIS THAT
WENT INTO THIS- GOVERNMENT
REORGANIZATION PROPOSAL. AND
THE PROBLEMS THAT SEEKS TO
SOLVE AND- I GUESS WHEN I LOOK
AT THE TIMELINE YOUR ONE TWO
THREE STANDING UP A SKELETON
STRUCTURE. YOUR ONE DOING
REGULATIONS IN YEAR TWO YEAR
THREE FINALIZING THE
REGULATIONS AND PRESUMABLY
BEGINNING TO DO WHATEVER IT IS
YOU'RE GOING TO DO WITH THIS
POPULATION WHOEVER THEY ARE
WHAT WHATEVER THEY ARE. WHAT
MAYBE THAT SUGGESTS THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO RUSH THIS
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR AND MAYBE WE
NEED TO TAKE THIS INTO THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE AND BUDGET
YEAR AND CONDUCT THE NORMAL
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE HEARINGS
THAT WE HAVE DONE IN PRIOR
GOVERNMENT REORGANIZATIONS- I
HAVE WAS TELLING SOMEONE
YESTERDAY AS PART OF MY LIFE
SIX YEARS AND BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FOR AS A CHAIR MY
COLLEAGUES AND I SPENT SEVERAL.
SESSIONS ON THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION REORGANIZATION
WHICH APPEARS TO BE TO HAVE
BEEN CONDUCTED IN A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT WAY. WITH A SLIGHTLY
DIG DIFFERENT DEGREE OF
ANALYSIS AND I'M NOT SURE THAT
THAT ANALYSIS THAT SAME PROCESS
AND ANALYSIS SHOULD NOT BE
UTILIZED IN THIS CASE. FROM
WHICH WAS NOT A QUESTION I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE STATEMENT LET
ME ASK A QUESTION NOW ABOUT
REGULATORY AUTHORITY IN LOOKING
AT OUR- SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
ANALYSIS ON PAGE THREE. IT
REFERENCES THE FACT THAT THE
NEW ORGANIZATION WILL BE
AUTHORIZED- TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS IDENTIFYING YOU
DEATHS IN CONNECTION WITH THE
OFFER OF CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES. BUT IN
THE SAME PARAGRAPH IT STATES
THAT THE TRAILER BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE ORGANIZATION TO
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS DEFINING
YOU DEPP'S BEFORE THE
DEPARTMENT NAY ENFORCE YOU DE
VIOLATIONS. DON'T YOU THINK IT
ODD THAT REGULATIONS WOULD NOT
BE PROMULGATED HAVING TO DO
WITH ENFORCEMENT POLICIES- SO
THAT THE ENTITIES BEING. MMHM
REGULATED WHETHER THEY ARE
CURRENT LICENSEES ARE THOSE
BEING REGULATED OR THOSE THAT
ARE PROPOSED TO BE REGULATED.
THANK YOU SENATOR I DO NOT
THINK IN THAT ODD- BECAUSE-
THE- THE THRUSTS OF A
PROHIBITION ON UNFAIR DECEPTIVE
OR ABUSIVE ACTS AND PRACTICES
PRESUMES THAT. SUCH PRACTICES
CAN CAN SHIFT OVER TIME ARE
VALUABLE OVER TIME AND SO THE
ACT OF THE FINING- A PARTICULAR
ACT OR PRACTICE- DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN. THAT YOU STOP
FUTURE- UNTOLD A DECEPTIVE OR
UNFAIR ACTS OR PRACTICES- AND
DIE YOU KNOW IN THIS REGARD I
HAVE TO RELY A LITTLE BIT ON MY
PRIOR EXPERIENCE AS AN
ENFORCEMENT ATTORNEY IT IS VERY
MUCH THE CASE. THAT IT IS AND
IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE FOR A
COMPANY TO ENGAGE IN. ACTS AND
PRACTICES THAT ARE INDIVIDUALLY.
NOT PROHIBITED BY LAW BUT WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU STITCH IT ALL
TOGETHER THE PROBLEM IS THE
PROBLEM MAY BE THAT YOU HAVE-
YOU HAVE. A COLLECTION OF. ACTS
AND PRACTICES THAT HARM
CONSUMERS AND SO THE TOUCHSTONE
I WOULD I WOULD SUBMIT THAT THE
TOUCHSTONE WITH RESPECT UNFAIR
ACTS AND PRACTICES. IS HOW WELL
IS A IS A COMPANY PAYING
ATTENTION TO ITS CONSUMERS ARE
THEY PAYING ATTENTION TO
WHETHER THEIR CONSUMERS ARE
BEING HARMED. THE BEST IN BREED
COMPANIES I'M CONVINCED VERY
CLOSE ATTENTION TO THE VOICE OF
THE CUSTOMER AND THEY DO A VERY
GOOD JOB OF REMEDIATING
CONSUMERS AS THEY COME UP. BUT
IT THE ACTORS. DON'T DO A GREAT
JOB OF DOING THAT. IS THE DBA
AND WILL THIS NEW. ENTITY
WHATEVER WE CALL IT. BE EXEMPT
FROM CO WITH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT NOW. DO YOU
ANTICIPATE HAVING PROMULGATING
AS THE AS THE AGENCY OR OR
GOVERNMENT ENTITY HEAD
ENFORCEMENT POLICIES. WE HAVE I
MEAN THE DEPARTMENT AS AS WE
STAND TODAY WE ALREADY HAVE AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM. IS SET
SET OUT IN REGULATION. I WOULD
ASSUME SO SENATOR BUT I AM
HAPPY TO- I'M HAPPY TO REVISIT
WITH GREATER SPECIFICITY ARE
YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THE-
SPECTER OF HAVING SOMEBODY
ACCUSED THIS NEW ENTITY OF
ADOPTING UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS WITHOUT COMPLIANCE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT IF WE WERE TO
PASS THIS TRAILER BILL AND-
AUTHORIZE YOU TO. NOT ISSUE
REGULATIONS HAVING TO DO WITH
YOUR ENFORCEMENT POLICIES AND
PRACTICES. SENATOR THE SCOPE
JUST TO CLARIFY THE AUTHORITY
TO PROHIBIT UNFAIR DECEPTIVE
ACTS AND PRACTICES WOULD BE
ROUTED- OUGHT TO BE ROUTED- IN
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND
THEN LEGISLATION AND SO IN THAT
REGARD I'M NOT SURE THAT WE ARE
OF COURSE EVER MINDFUL OF THE
SPECTER OF UNDERGROUND
REGULATION- BITES. THAT IS THAT
IS OF COURSE- OF A PROCESS THAT
WE THAT WE UNDERTAKEN AVOID
TODAY WELL HAVING DONE SOME
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA WITH.
BUSINESSES IN FRONT OF AGENCIES
ACT I CAN ASSURE YOU THE MOST
BUSINESSES WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THE RULES ARE. AND I THINK MOST
OF THEM IF THEY KNOW THE RULES
OF COMPLY BUT IF THE RULES ARE
SOMEHOW NOT SET OUT AND REYES.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE STATUTE
CAN'T COVER. MOST IF NOT ALL OF
THE VARIOUS- ITERATIONS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE ENFORCED IT'S A
VERY DIFFICULT POSITION FOR A
BUSINESS. AND BECOME SORT OF A
GOTCHA SITUATION SO YOU MAY
WANT TO YOU MAY WANT TO
REEVALUATE THAT PARTICULAR
PROVISION OF THE TROUBLE ONE
FINAL QUESTION MADAM CHAIR THE
LEGAL ENFORCEMENT DIVISION I
COULD NOT TELL FROM THE TRAILER
BILL AND DID NOT. HAVE TIME
HAVE THE B. C. P. HOW MANY.
ATTORNEYS WILL BE ADDED TO THAT
DIVISION WELL THAT TO THAT
DIVISION I GUESS IS MY QUESTION.
SIXTEEN AT SIXTEEN F. T. E.'S
INTO ENFORCEMENT WHICH ARE NOT
ALL NECESSARILY ATTORNEYS- SOME
OF THAT NUMBER OF MAY- MAY
COMPRISE INVESTIGATORS AND- NON
INTEREST. AS WELL AS-
INTERNATIONAL POSITIONS WITHIN
THE LEGAL DIVISION- WITHIN THE
LEGAL DIVISION SO ENFORCEMENT
AND LEGAL OUR ARE SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT. DIVISIONS WELL LISTEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING UP WITH
MY QUESTIONS YOUR RESPONSES
WERE. A VERY PROFESSIONAL AND-
INAPPROPRIATE AND I DO
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. SENATOR NIELSEN FOLLOWED
BY SENATORS WHITE HOUSE SKI
MORLOCK AND THEY'RE ALSO. A
COMMISSIONER ALVAREZ. FIRST OF
ALL AS A MATTER PROCESS. THIS
IS AN ABUSIVE NOT A CORRECTION
A CORRUPTION. ABOUT PROCESS. A
TRAILER BILL IS NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BUDGET THIS GOT NOTHING TO DO
WITH THAT THIS IS A BRAND NEW
COMPLETE IDEA. A BRAND NEW
ENTITY. AND YOU'RE GOING TO
CIRCUMVENT THE MORE IN DEPTH
REVIEW OF A PROCESS BY THIS END
RUN. AND RUN AT THE END OF
SESSION WITH ONLY A FEW DAYS
LEFT TO GO. THE PUBLIC GOT TO
BE VERY ALARMED ABOUT THAT SIR
NOW THAT'S JUST TO A GENERAL
PRACTICING REMARK AND THAT'S
ENOUGH FOR ME TO VOTE NO. IN
ITSELF. BUT THE LACK OF
SPECIFICITY HERE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RIVERSIDE IS EXPLORED IN
GREAT DEPTH. BUT WE FELT IT
IT'S A NEBULOUS PROPOSAL IS
WHAT I WOULD CALL IT AT THIS
POINT. THAT WE'RE GOING TO
REGULATE QUOTE ANY COVERED
PERSON WHAT THE HECK IS A
COVERED PERSON IS THERE ANY
DOCUMENT THAT DEFINES WHAT A
COVERED PERSON IS. YOU USE THE
WORD YOU WERE THINKING ABOUT.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU'VE
DECIDED AND YOU HAVE A PLAN
THAT YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT YOUR
DEVELOPING A PROCESS.
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY WHAT IS
THE ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY IS A
STATUTE GOING TO BE THE
CITATION OF AUTHORITY WHEN
THEIR LAWSUITS. IF IT IS IT'S
GOING TO BE A VERY WEAK. BASIS
AND I READ READ THIS AS PURPOSE
SIMPLY PURPOSEFULLY TRYING TO
EXEMPT THE AGENCY. FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
SO YOU CAN RUN AND FUNCTION ON
UNDERGROUND REGULATION TO DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT **** NILLY
WE DARE NOT LET THAT CANCER. IN
FACT OUR BODIES OF LAW HERE.
AND YOU HAVE NOT GIVEN US ANY
REAL EVIDENCE OF SOMETHING THAT
IS SO BROKEN. THAT REQUIRES
SUCH A DRASTIC GROWTH OF A NEW
AGENCY. N. AS I ASSESS THE
NUMBERS HERE WE'RE OVER A
HUNDRED P. WISE JUST TO START
THIS. SHIPPED IN THE CHANNEL.
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
INDICATION OF GREGIS VIOLATIONS.
THAT THIS IS SUPPOSED TO FIX.
AND WHATNOT DIGIT QUOTE
MILESTONES NEED TO BE CODIFIED.
SO WE THE LEGISLATURE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT YOUR PLANT IS.
SUFFICE TO SAY THE- PRACTICING
REMARKS ARE JUST. A SCATTERING
OF CONCERNS. BUT THERE ARE
SERIOUS SERIOUS CONCERNS
COMMISSIONER ALVAREZ. CAN YOU
PUT ME AT EASE ABOUT ANY OF
THESE OBSERVATIONS. THAT I OR
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE MADE.
SENATOR. WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
RISK. WE NOW WITH THAT
ECONOMIC- DOWNTURNS AND
DISLOCATIONS LEAD TO BAD
BEHAVIOR IN THE IN THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL- MARKETPLACE- IT WAS
AN OBSERVABLE PHENOMENA AND-
200-082-0009 TWO THOUSAND TEN-
AND I THINK WE ARE JUST NOW
STARTING TO SEE THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG BY. THE INCREASED
VOLUME OF CONSUMER COMPLAINTS-
AND SO I AND I UNDERSTAND- I
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE LACK OF GRANULARITY
AROUND FOR EXAMPLE- THE 40%
SPIKE IN CONSUMER COMPLAINTS
BUT I WOULD SUBMIT THAT THE-
SURGE IN VOLUME- WITHIN THIS
FIRST QUARTER ESSENTIALLY OF
THE CODE AND DEMOCRATS- IS
ITSELF. ILLUSTRATIVE IN
TELLING- DENSO SENATOR WHAT
WHAT I WOULD SAY IN THIS REGARD
IS THAT WE HAVE I BELIEVE WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET OUT
HOW DOES- WHAT WHAT IS
POTENTIALLY- A VERY SEVERE AND
DISASTROUS. ECONOMIC
DISLOCATION FOR- FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS- AND I THINK WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO- TO CHECK IN
IN RE VISIT- PROGRESS
INCREMENTAL STEPS. IF I'M WRONG
ABOUT THAT PREDICTION I BELIEVE
ME I'M HAPPY TO BE WRONG- BUT I
DON'T I AM WORRIED I WOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT FAILING TO ACT
SWIFTLY ENOUGH AND- HAVING TO
DEAL WITH A LONG TAIL PROBLEM.
INTO THE FUTURE- WHEN WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TAX INNER. LET HIM
SHOW JUST A COUPLE MORE WORDS.
IF I MAY. FAMOUS WORDS OF
GOVERNMENT. TO CITIZENS WE NOW.
WE GOVERNMENT NO. WHAT'S BEST.
AND THESE ARE CHALLENGING
ECONOMIC TIMES. CALIFORNIA HAS
A BIG ENOUGH PROBLEM. THE
NEGATIVE IMAGE TO ATTRACT
BUSINESS TO THE STATE. HERE'S
ANOTHER NAIL IN THE COFFIN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
THIRTY MIL SO I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY YOU COMMENTED ON ONE
HUNDRED F. T. E.'S I JUST
WANTED TO RESTATE THE CORRECT
IN THE AGENDA. THAT BY THE END
OF TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE THE
ANTICIPATE. NINETY F. TEASERS
WHEN TO MAKE SURE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT CORRECTION THANK YOU
CENTER BY CAL SKI. MISTER
PETERS I APPRECIATE THE INFO
COMMERCIAL LINE SB NINE OH
EIGHT FOR COMMISSIONER ALVAREZ
AND MISS HARPER ST I'M- LET'S
PRETEND WE BOTH ARE LUCKY THAT.
SB NINE AWAIT BECOMES LAW SO
THAT MEANS IN JANUARY ONE ALL
DEBT COLLECTORS WILL HAVE TO
HAVE TO BE LICENSED IN THIS
TRAILER BILL BECOMES LAW
IMMEDIATELY LIKE SEPTEMBER
FIRST. AND YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
NEWLY COVER PERSONS WHICH WOULD
NEED HAVE TO BE REGISTERED. HOW
DO YOU ANTICIPATE BEING THE
HARMONIZATION AND- OF THOSE TWO
ACTIVITIES N. WOULD WE WANT TO
HAVE. DEBT COLLECTORS REGISTER
WHEN WE KNOW THAT THERE TO GET
A LICENSE COME JANUARY FIRST.
THANK YOU SENATOR- I SHOULD I
SHOULD NOTE AT THE OUTSET THAT-
THE DEPARTMENT- DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION ON SB
NINE AWAITS- BUT I CAN SAY-
THAT. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL- WAS STRUCTURED WAS
WAS INTENT WAS STRUCTURED AND
IS INTENDED TO ACCOMPANY.
LEGISLATIVE LICENSURE BILLS AND
SO WE CERTAINLY ENVISIONED
PROVIDING- THE LEGISLATURE- ANY
ANY DATA AND INFORMATION THAT
MIGHT NEED TO. NOT TOO BAD TO
BATH INFORM POLICY AND
LICENSING STRUCTURES. ARE ON.
OUR INTENTION IS THAT LICENSING
STRUCTURES AND THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL- WORK WORK IN HARMONY-
IT IS- I WOULD ALSO BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T NOTICE- AS AS IS.
EXISTING ON THE REGISTRATION
STRUCTURE OF COURSES IS SIMPLY
THAT AND THE LICENSING
STRUCTURE- DEPENDING ON HOW IT
IS- HOW IS ARCHITECTED- MAY.
MAY EQUIRE- CHOIR SUPERVISORY
ACTIVITY WITHIN A PRESCRIBED
PERIOD OF TIME WHICH IS WHICH
IS ALL WELL AND GOOD THAT IS OF
COURSE A- A CORE FUNCTION OF
OUR OF THE CURRENT DEPARTMENT
OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT- I WOULD
SIMPLY NOTE THAT THE- THE
INVESTMENT REQUIRED. TO ENSURE
THAT- THE LICENSING EXAMINATION
CYCLE CAN BE COMPLETED WITHIN A
PRESCRIBED PERIOD OF TIME- IS
LIKELY TO BE HIGHER THAN- THAN
FOR INSTANCE A REGISTRATION
SCHEME AT THE OUTSET. RECORD
WOULDN'T YOU AGREE THAT
SOMEBODY BEFORE TRYING TO STOP
ABUSIVE UNFAIR AND DECEPTIVE
ACTIVITY AND IF YOU HAVE A
LICENSE IN ORDER JUST TO DO
BUSINESS IN THE STATE. YOU WERE
MORE LIKELY NOT OR YOU WOULD
YOU WOULD LOSE YOUR LICENSE IF
YOU DIDN'T DO THAT IF YOU'RE AN
UNREGULATED ENTITY YOU MAY JUST
GET. FINED OR HAVE TO GIVE A
CONSUMER BACK THEIR MONEY BUT
YOU YOU CAN IF YOU'RE AN
LICENSE YOU CAN CONTINUE TAX.
RUN YOUR BUSINESS VERSUS A
LICENSE PERSON THIS IS DONE AM
I CORRECT IN THAT DO YOU DIRECT.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHAT WHAT I
WOULD SAY I WOULD I WOULD SAY
AS A GENERAL MATTER AGAIN
DEPENDING ON HOW A LICENSING
SCHEME IS ARCHITECTED A
LICENSING SCHEME MAY VERY WELL
BE- MORE- ME VERY WELL- ALLOW
FOR MORE PUNITIVE- RESPONSES TO
BAD BEHAVIOR WITHIN WITHIN A
GIVEN INDUSTRY OR SECTOR. I'M
NOT I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE'S IT
SEEMS THAT THERE'S THREE GROUPS
OF PEOPLE THERE'S THESE NEWLY
COVERED PERSONS. AND CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG BUT- THE DPO IS
GOING TO DECIDE IF THERE. IS
SOME OF THESE NEWLY COVER
PERSON HAS TO BE REGISTERED AND
THEN THERE'S THIS CLASS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LICENSE
LICENSES IS THAT. IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING THE THREE SORT OF
GROUPS OF FOLKS THAT WERE DOING
THAT MAY BE INVOLVED IN THE
PEACE OF. UNFAIR AND DECEPTIVE
ACTS. I APOLOGIZE SENATOR I
TRACKED- I TRACK WOULD YOU MIND
RESTATING BECAUSE I TRACK TO
TWO CLASSES. WE HAVE NEWLY
COVERED PERSONS WHO COULD BE
YOU DID YOU DECIDE OF THAT
NEWLY COVER PERSON BECOMES A
REGISTRANT OR NOT. BY TO YOU
COULD YOU COULD HAVE A EWLY
COVER PERSON THAT DOESN'T HAVE
TO REGISTER. ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING EVERYBODY ANY ANY
DEEMED NEARLY COVER PERSON
YOU'RE GOING TO REGISTER A
MALL. WE ANTICIPATE SO WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE GOING THROUGH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS TO
ARTICULATE- TO. ESSENTIALLY
DEFINE THE REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS OF A OF A NEARLY
COVERED PERSON POPULATION. OKAY
ALL RIGHT- SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S SOME LICENSEES NOW
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LICENSE BETTER
TO BE EXAM FROM. THIS ACTION
TO. THEY HAVE THE STATE IN THE
FEDERAL LAWS REGARDING THIS
ABUSIVE DECEPTIVE ACTIVITY AND
THEN BE EXEMPT FROM PAYING. A
CONSUMER BACK TO REFUND. WHICH
IS INVOLVING INACTION OF THEIR
LICENSE AND HAVING THEM EXAM
FROM YOU KNOW HAVING TO GIVE UP
TO SUIT SORT OF BILL GOTTEN
GAINS- THAT CONCERNS ME THAT
CONCERNS ME SO WHAT WHAT I'M
WORRIED ABOUT IS THAT IS A LOOK
WE'RE GETTING. A LITTLE
CONFUSION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT
THAT YOU WOULD BE DOING AND
WHETHER YOU'RE GONNA GO TO
SUPERIOR COURT AND TRY TO GET
THE CONSUMER BACK TO REFUND AT
MY UNDERSTANDING OF DODD DODD
FRANK IS THAT WE WANT TO HAVE
THESE THINGS DONE
ADMINISTRATIVELY AND NOT HAVE
TO GO INTO COURT EVERY DAY- TO
RECEIVE THAT WHAT DO YOU HOLD A
LICENSE OR WHETHER YOU'RE
REGISTERING. IS THAT HOW YOU
SEE THE PROGRAM GOING. THANK
SENATOR DODD ET SO DODD FRANK
DOES IN MY VIEW CONTEMPLATES-
PURSUING APPROPRIATE-
APPROPRIATE PENALTIES AND
REMEDIES. IN EITHER- THE CIVIL
CIVIL COURT ACTION- WAR
ADMINISTRATIVELY- USE- IT
HIGHLIGHTED A- PARTICULAR SET
OF CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED
WHICH IS WHICH IS WHICH IS TO
SAY WHETHER- WHETHER DODD FRANK
IN FACT SUPPLANTS. EXISTING
ADMINISTRATIVE- FRAMEWORKS AND
THAT IS A CONVERSATION THAT
THAT I- THE CONVERSATION OR
ONE OF THE FINAL CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE BEEN HAVING- WITH SOME OF
OUR- WITH SOME OF OUR EXISTING
LICENSEES AND WHAT I WOULD SAY
AGAIN IS WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE
STRIVING FOR IS. A MORE LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD- SO THAT THERE
IS- A UNIFORM SET OF MINIMUM
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS- TO WHICH
WE CAN HOLD ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR THEM THE EXISTING LICENSEES
WANT TO FORCE YOU TO TAKE HIM
INTO COURT RATHER THAN HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDING UNDER.
THEIR LCENSE AND DODD FRANK IN
ORDER TO RESOLVE THE ABUSIVE
UNFAIR AND DECEPTIVE ACTS THAT
THEY'VE ENGAGED IN. I THAT HAS
BEEN MY UNDERSTANDING AGAIN IS
THAT THAT IS ONE OF THE-
PERSPECTIVE. OFFERED UP BY AT
LEAST SONG ARE INCUMBENT
LICENSEES. THANK YOU SENATOR Y.
CASKEY SENATOR MORE LOCK WILL
BE FOLLOWED BY US INTO THEIR
ALSO MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU
COMMISSIONER ALVAREZ HI. I WISH
THAT. ERECTOR OF THE DMV WOULD
HAVE CONTACTED US EARLY ON AND
SAID I NEED MORE STAFFING
BECAUSE WE SEE. A GROWTH IN
DEMAND BECAUSE OF REAL ID
SOUGHT BY A FIRM YOU AND. YOUR
CONCERN ABOUT WHAT MAY BE AN
INCREASE IN CERTAIN FINANCIAL
SHENANIGANS OR OR- WHATEVER WE
WANNA WE WANNA CALL A FINANCIAL
ABUSE SO WITH THAT I IDEA. EVER
ALREADY COVERED YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO FIX AND WHY IT
NEEDS A NEW NAME AND WHY IT
NEEDS A 15% INCREASE IN
STAFFING WE REDISCOVERED THE
DISCUSS THE YOU DON'T HAVE A
WRITTEN BUSINESS PLAN. AND IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THIS IS A
FALLS UNDER G. R. P. WHICH WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER THIS MORNING
GOVERNOR'S A REORGANIZATION
PROPOSAL BUT WHAT I AM I
HAVEN'T. SEEN ASKED YET IS WHY
ARE WE- UNDER THE IMPRESSION
THE ATTORNEY. IS FAILING- OR
FALLING SHORT- TO REQUIRE THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU SENATOR
YOU KNOW TO BE CLEAR I WOULD- I
WOULD SAY THAT. IN THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE HAS DONE A TREMENDOUS
JOB OF PROSECUTING
INVESTIGATING AND PROSECUTING.
MEANINGFUL CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION ACTIONS. WEBER OVER
THE LAST DECADE AND LONGER-
THEIR CONSUMER LAW SECTION OF
COURSE HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
BRINGING MEANINGFUL ACTION AND
REDRESS THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. BUT IT'S I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO- TO
REALIZE THAT THE AG'S CONSUMER
LAW SECTION IS BUT ONE SECTION-
WHOSE MANDATE IS ARE QUITE
BROAD IS BROADER THAN SIMPLY
CONSERVE OUR FINANCIAL
PROTECTION- AND IN OUR
CONVERSATION WITH THEM I THINK
IT IS. FAIR TO SAY THAT THEY-
THEY BELIEVE THAT ADDITIONAL
HELP- WOULD BE WOULD BE
WARRANTED AND APPROPRIATE AND
SO I DON'T. YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW. THAT WE SEE THIS AS
SUPPLANTING YOUR SERVICE ANY OF
THE GOOD WORK THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS HAS DONE
THIS THERE IS SIMPLY- REAL
PRACTICAL RECOGNITION THAT
THERE IS VALUE. TO HAVING- A
DEDICATED CONSUMER FINANCIAL-
AGENCY AT THE STATE LEVEL- THAT
CAN GO A LITTLE MORE BROADLY-
DOWN THAT CAN CURRENTLY BE
COVERED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE THE OTHER
THING. I WOULD OFFER UP IS THE
FOLLOWING. WHEN DOT WAS WHEN
THAT THOUSAND DOLLARS ACT WAS
PASSED. AGAIN IT IT IN. A
PROVISION THAT ESSENTIALLY
AUTHORIZES EVERY ATTORNEY
GENERAL IN THE COUNTRY. TO USE
THE TOOLS WITHIN DODD FRANK THE
TOOLS IN THE REMEDIES-
ARTICULATED IN DODD FRANK
AGAINST- AGAINST BAD ACTORS IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE STATES THAT
WAS. TEN YEARS AGO AND- AGAIN
WELL I AM UNABLE TO PRESENTS-
GRANULAR STATISTICS I THINK- I
THINK WE WILL I WOULD BE HARD
PRESSED TO CONCLUDE THAT- THAT
WE HAVE SEEN. A RATIFICATION OF
BAD BEHAVIOR AND THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL- SERVICES SPACE OVER
THE LAST DECADE. SO THIS
MORNING I ASKED THE QUESTION
MAY BE ASKED TO HAVE YOU AS
WELL SORT OF FEELS MY GUESS WE
USE THE TERM SEAT WHAT'S THE
SEED OF THE IDEA. OF EXPANDING
YOUR DEPARTMENT CHANGING. WHAT
IT DOES WHAT IS JURISDICTION
IS- WAS IT A LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION REPORT AND ELLIE A
REPORT A STATE AUDITOR REPORT.
OR IS IT JUST BECAUSE OF SOME
CONCERN ABOUT DODD FRANK. THANK
YOU SENATOR I WOULD SAY THAT
CONCERNS ABOUT DODD FRANK WERE-
AS FACTOR BUT CERTAINLY NOT THE
SINGLE FACTOR- I THINK THE
UNDERLYING MOTIVATION REALLY
HAD MORE TO DO WITH WITH THE
FOLLOWING TWO QUESTIONS NUMBER
ONE- HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA- ROMANES- REMAINS
EIGHT A LEADER IN THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION SPACE AND
AGAIN THIS. THIS THAT BACK
QUESTION PREDATES THE CURRENT
CODE PANDEMIC- BUT I THINK
THERE'S A- THERE IS A REAL
IMPRACTICAL RECOGNITION THAT
AGAIN CALIFORNIA HAS A WORLD
CLASS ECONOMY- AND IT. IT IS
DESERVING OF A I THE WORLD
CLASS. DEPARTMENT AGAIN ONE
WITH ROBUST TOOLS ROBUST AND
DIVERSE TOOLS INCLUDING SOME OF
THESE MARKET MONITORING
FUNCTION THAT CAN HELP- THAT
CAN HELP BETTER INFORM
POLICYMAKING BUT ALSO THEY CAN
FRANKLY HELP- MARKETPLACE
PARTICIPANTS BETTER UNDERSTAND-
THE MACRO THE MACROECONOMIC
FIELD- AND THEN SECONDLY YOU
KNOW THE QUESTION IS THAT THE
SECOND QUESTION- THAT THIS
PROPOSAL SEEKS THAT THE BALANCE
HOW IT IS. AND WE ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA REMAINS A LEADER IN
INNOVATION WITH RESPECT TO
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES AND THERE AGAIN THERE
IS A PRACTICAL RECOGNITION OF
THE ACT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS-
DANIEL LEADER IN INNOVATION
OVER THE LAST DECADE AT LEAST
ARE GOING BACK TO YOU KNOW- HOW
WE INTERACT WITH THE MOVEMENT
OF MONEY- WITH THE RISE OF
COMPANIES LIKE. HOW AND SQUARE
IN STRIPE. THIS IS THAT YOU
KNOW I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THAT THERE IS A TREND THERE
THAT IS IRREVERSIBLE AND SO IT
IS IN MY VIEW JUST AS IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE RETOOL OUR
CAPABILITIES THE STATE LEVEL.
SO THAT WE CAN. APPROPRIATELY
NAMED BILLY- SO THAT'S- I SAW
THAT BACK KIND OF INNOVATION
CAN CONTINUE TO THRIVE AND TAKE
PLACE IN A RESPONSIBLE MANNER.
COMMISSIONER ELVIS THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR VISION- I'M
ALSO I JUST WANNA SHARE OF
INCLUDE INCLUSION WHAT I'M
SEEING AND- JUST RECENTLY
CHARLES SCHWAB- MERGED WITH TD
AMERITRADE IT WAS A TWENTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS ALL STOCK DEAL.
SCHWAB IS HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA AMERITRADE WAS
HEADQUARTERED NEBRASKA. AND
AFTER THE MERGER THE NEW
HEADQUARTERS IS IN THE STATE
TAXES SO I'M I'M NERVOUS ABOUT.
WHAT KIND OF MESSAGE WE'RE
SENDING TO FINANCIAL PROVIDERS-
IN A LOT OF AREAS- SO I HAVE
SOME MISGIVINGS BUT IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT. YOU COULD TAKE YOUR
EXISTING DEPARTMENT AT THE
STAFF AND THEN IMAGES PROPOSED
THE LEGISLATIVE FIXES YOU WANT
AND HOPEFULLY THEY'LL DEFINE
WHAT A SERVICE PROVIDER IS IT
WHAT A MATERIAL SERVICES AND WE
HAVE A CHANCE TO BET THOSE AND
SO I THINK YOU. COMMISSIONER
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU THIRTY DORADO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I VERY MUCH
BELIEVE IN STRENGTHENING AND
PROTECTING CONSUMER RIGHTS.
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS TO A
LOW PAID ALL WORKERS OF
FAMILIES ESPECIALLY WITH
REGARDS TO COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
I'D LIKE TO THINK I'VE VOTED
FOR EVERYTHING THAT IN ANY WAY
STRENGTHENS STRENGTHENS. ON
THEIR RIGHT TO BE TREATED
FAIRLY NOT TO BE SCARED. AND
FROM THAT POINT OF VIEW THAT
SAYS WE DON'T NEED TO DO
ANYTHING MORE. BUT I'M COMING
FROM THE POINT OF VIEW THAT. WE
ARE FACING RIGHT NOW. AND WE
KEEP HEARING ABOUT IT AND LEGAL
HOME AND TO OUR DISTRICTS AND
WE TALKED TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THEY ARE FACING LIFE AND DEATH.
LIFE AND DEATH. ALL I HEAR
ABOUT WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE TELLING ME IS
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THEIR LIVES
HOW AT WORK THEY'RE AFRAID TO
GO TO WORK BECAUSE THEY'RE
GONNA GET CONTAGIOUS. AT THE
SAME TIME IF THEY DON'T GO TO
WORK THEY DON'T HAVE. THE MONEY.
TO BUY FOOD FOR OUR PAY THE
RENT. WE HAVE IN SPITE OF AN
EVICTION MORATORIUM WE HAVE. IN
JUST FORTY FOUR COUNTY SIXTEEN
HUNDRED EVICTIONS IN THE LAST
FEW MONTHS AND THAT'S NOT
COUNTING L. A. COUNTY. AND THE
FOURTEEN OTHER COUNTIES WE HAVE
AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS A WEEK AND WAGE
THEFT. THE SIX MILLION DOLLARS
JUST IN L. A. COUNTY WAGE THEFT.
SO IF SOMEBODY TRIES TO SAY
THAT WE'RE ALL CONCERNED ABOUT.
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES. I DON'T
DOUBT YOUR CONCERN BUT I DOUBT
THAT WE'RE GIVING THE KIND OF.
SPECIAL FOCUS THAT NEEDS TO BE-GIVEN TO THESE VERY CRITICAL
AND URGENT MATTERS. WILLIAM WE
WANT TO PROTECT THE WORLD CLASS
ECONOMY I THINK THE WHAT BEST
WHERE DEFENDING THAT REPUTATION
IS BY. REALLY TAKING CARE OF
EVERYBODY WHO WORKS FOR THIS
ECONOMY. AND I SAY ALL OF THAT
YOU MIGHT THINK IT DOESN'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THIS ISSUE.
I'M TRYING TO FIND OUT WHAT IT
IS. ABOUT MOVING FORWARD WITH
THE PROPOSAL LIKE THIS THAT IS
SO URGENT. AND I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT IS IT THAT. LEAD YOU ALL
THE MEASURE THE URGENCY TO DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS ADD STAFF
IN THE DEPARTMENT- THE INCREASE
THE FUNDING FOR THAT DEPARTMENT
WHEN. THE REST OF THE WORLD IS
THINKING ABOUT HOW MY GONNA
LIVE HOW MY GONNA SURVIVE. WHAT
ABOUT PAYING THE RENT SCARED TO
DEATH ABOUT GETTING THE BIG
THAT LIKE THEY SEE HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE DOING I HAVE YET TO HEAR
FROM YOU. A REALLY COMPELLING
CASE TO SHOW THE URGENCY OF
DOING THIS NOW. YES NOBODY
WANTS TO NOBODY WANTS TO ANSWER
WHO WOULD WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
DIRECTED TO SENATOR THE
COMMISSIONER OF FINANCE. OF THE
COMMISSION AND FINANCE.
COMMISSIONER. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. I OF
COURSE- CANNOT DISPUTE ANY OF
THE- MANY OF THE- OUR CONCERN
THAT YOU ARTICULATE. AND I
THINK IT IS VERY MUCH D.
CONCERNED THAT YOUR TO KELLY
THAT- THAT ANIMATES- THE
URGENCY OF THIS PROPOSAL. THE
CONCERN OF COURSE IS THAT AS-
AS PEOPLE ARE. AS PEOPLE ARE
DRIVEN TO ITS FINANCIAL BRINK
THEY- ARE THEY BECOME MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO. FINANCIAL
PREDATION- AND THAT'S A
SITUATION THAT WE'RE STRIVING
TO AVOID. AND I THINK THAT THAT
GOES HAND IN HAND WITH. WITH
SOME OF WITH WITH THE OBJECTIVE
OF. ENSURING THAT PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH- THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC IN CRISIS- AS
BEST POSSIBLE. WITHOUT WITHOUT
HITTING OR RESORTING TO. OTHER
SOCIAL SERVICE THAT'S- SO I
WOULD. YOU KNOW I WOULD I WOULD.
I WOULD OFFER THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S VERY MUCH ANIMATED
BY- THAT CONCERN THAT- PEOPLE
AND- IN THE MOST VULNERABLE THE
MOST VULNERABLE POSITIONS TODAY
WILL REMAIN THE MOST VULNERABLE
POSITIONS OF TOMORROW AND- WILL
REMAIN THOSE THAT ARE MOST
SUBJECT TO FINANCIAL PREDATION
WHICH WE ARE TRYING TO PROTECT
AGAINST. THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS
ONLY MOVE ONTO CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU ON. FOR THE
COMMISSION I BELIEVE THIS THIS
QUESTION HAS BEEN. ADDRESS
SPREAD I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY SO THAT
WE- THAT THE DODD FRANK ACT IN
EFFECT INVITED STATES TO
DEVELOP PROGRAMS SUCH AS WHAT'S
BEING PROPOSED HERE AND TO
EMPOWER THEIR FINANCIAL
REGULATORS. TO PROHIBITS. THE
LICENSEES FROM ENGAGING IN
VARIOUS PRACTICES AND THAT TOO
IN ORDER TO- PURSUE RESTITUTION
OR WHATEVER TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO TO COURT
SO I THINK THAT IS BEEN. BUT
WHATEVER THE QUESTIONS ARE SO
FAR ASKED IS PRETTY MUCH.
ASCERTAINED THAT IT MIGHT
CORRECT. I BELIEVE YOU'RE
CORRECT SENATOR- THE PROVISION-
I THINK THE PRINT THE MATERIAL
PROVISION IN DODD FRANK
PROVIDES THE STATE REGULATOR
MAY BRING A CIVIL ACTION OR
OTHER PROCEEDING SO THE FACT
THAT WE HAVEN'T DONE SO YET
MEANING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DIDN'T ACT YET WE I MEAN YES
CERTAINLY IT'S LOOK WE COULD
ALLEGEDLY. DISCUSSED WHETHER WE
FEEL IT'S- RIGHT THIS CURRENT
MOMENT IS THE TIME TO DO SO
BUT- THE FACT THAT WE HAVEN'T
YET ISN'T A MATTER OF THAT IT
IS NOT AN APPROPRIATE ACTION TO
DO. N. A. I'M A WELL I SHARE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT CREATING
NEW POSITIONS RIGHT NOW IN THIS
TIME OF- ECONOMIC DOWNTURN I'M
ALSO QUITE AWARE- IN MY OWN
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE WE JUST
DEALT WITH THE SOME INCREASED-
PENALTIES FOR I'M GONNA BLOW IT
THE- OF PRICE GOUGING THE SO.
THROUGH BASICALLY IN MY OWN
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE WE'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH A NUMBER OF
BILLS THAT WERE BROUGHT FORWARD
BECAUSE OF EGREGIOUS PRACTICES
THE VARIOUS ENTITIES HAVE BEEN
ENGAGING IN NOW TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF PEOPLE BECAUSE OF
THE PRESSURE EITHER THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING ECONOMICALLY OR DO
DISCOVERED CRISIS SO IN THAT
RESPECT. IT I FEEL THE ONE
COULD MAKE A STRONG ARGUMENT
THAT WHAT IS BEING PROPOSED
HERE IS NEEDED NOW BECAUSE OUR
CONSUMERS ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE AND ALSO FACING
PARTICULAR- HARDSHIPS- D. THE
MAIN QUESTION I THINK WAS
REALLY BEEN ADDRESSED BECAUSE
OF THEOTHER ONE I WAS GOING TO
ASK IS- JUST THAT CONFORMITY
WITH DODD FRANK BUT I THINK
ENOUGH PEOPLE HAVE ADDRESSED
THAT- AND YOU HAVE JUST
REINFORCE THAT IT'S THAT IT IS
OUR RIGHT. SO I FEEL LIKE THE
ADMINISTRATION FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT THE FEDERAL
LAW ALLOWS US TO DO HAS TAKEN
THE RIGHT APPROACH THEN I ALSO
FEEL THAT RIGHT NOW WE ARE
SEEING THAT- OUR CURRENT BREAKS
DO YOU HAVE GAPS THAT HAVE LEFT
THE NUMBER OF PRODUCTS SERVICES
AND COMPANIES OUTSIDE OF OUR
DEPARTMENT SECURITY AND THAT
THIS DOES BUILD ON THE MODEL
THAT THE FEDERAL CONSUMER
PROTECTION BUREAU WAS
ESTABLISHED FOR HOWEVER
UNFORTUNATELY THE FEDERAL THE
FEDS HAVE GUTTED THAT SO THAT
IS ANOTHER ARGUMENT I THINK FOR
NOW IF THE- IF THE TERM
PROTECTION BOROUGH FEDERALLY
WAS WAS OPERATING AS IT WAS
INTENDED IN FIRST ESTABLISHED.
PERHAPS THAT WE NEED TO ACT
RIGHT NOW BUT I THINK THAT
BECAUSE WERE NOT BEING PROVIDED
THOSE SAFEGUARDS AND BECAUSE WE
DO KNOW THAT OUR CONSUMERS ARE
UNDER A LOT OF ODD DID JUDE-
PRESSURE ALL GUESTS FOR LACK OF
BETTER WORD THAT IT THIS SEEMS
TO ME TO BE AN APPROPRIATE
PROPOSAL RIGHT NOW AS DIFFICULT
AS OUR. FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
THANK YOU SENATORS CARE I'LL
JUST NOTE THAT SO OF THE
QUESTIONS MEMBERS REYES OF.
COULD ALSO POSSIBLY BE ANSWERED
BY OUR PANEL THAT WILL COME
NEXT I WANT TO ENCOURAGE PALACE
THAT IF YOU'RE HEARING
QUESTIONS YOU'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
THE FEEL FREE TO INCORPORATE
THAT INTO YOUR PRESENTATION-
SENATOR PAN AND THAT. SORT OF
THE COMING YEAR- WILL BE- OUR
LAST MEMBER BEFORE WE MOVE TO
THE PANEL SENATOR FAN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- I APPRECIATE I
WAS ACTUALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM THE PANEL BUT
THEN- SIR KASKI HAS HAD SOME
QUESTIONS I WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON. AND CERTAINLY CEDIT IS
SOMETHING THAT- ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS CRISIS- THIS
PANDEMIC WHICH IS LEADING TO A
FINANCIAL CRISIS THAT I KNOW
THAT BUSINESSES I MEAN DOWN THE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER. IT
COUNTING ON AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUALS TO TRY TO GET
THROUGH THIS FINANCIAL CRISIS
CERATOPSIANS TO BACK OUT HE
SAID TALKED ABOUT THE THREE
CLASSES RIGHT AND SO WE HAVE
THE PEOPLE LICENSE WE KNOW WHO
THEY ARE. AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SENSUALLY THESE
COVERED PERSONS. SOME OF WHOM
WILL BE ASKED TO REGISTER AND I
WASN'T CLEAR FROM THE
COMMISSIONER WHETHER THEY WERE
GONNA BE QUOTE COVERED PERSONS
WHO WEREN'T AND EXACTLY WHO'S A
COVERED PERSON SO. I COULD
COULD THERE BE A CLEARER
UNDERSTANDING OF IT IS THE
INTENTION OF THE ADMINISTRATION
ISN'T IT AND THIS TRAILER BILL
THAT ANYONE WHO ENGAGES IN ANY
FORM NO MATTER HOW LARGE OR
SMALL OR WHATEVER OF. IT WOULD
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO REGISTER-
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
SAY ORDER ACTUALLY THERE IS A-
SCALE OR SOME POINT NOW SOME
GROUP THAT IS THAT THIS COULD
BE US TO REGISTER ANOTHER GROUP
WHO PERHAPS BECAUSE- ARE NOT.
CONTENT IT IS AS THAT AND
FIGURED OUT IS THAT GOING TO BE
DEALT LATER IS THAT SOMETHING
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT NOW. THANK
YOU CENTERS SO THE ARCHITECTURE
OF THE- PROPOSAL'S SEEMS THAT
THE. THAT THAT COVERED PERSONS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO REGISTER
BUT IN ORDER TO DETERMINE- SO
EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO MIGHT
FALL UNDER THAT DEFINITION
WOULD HAVE TO REGISTER. RIGHT
SO AS PART OF THE REGULATORY
PROCESS IN OKAY AND WORKS AND I
UNDERSTAND THE DEFINITION OF A
COVERED PERSONS ANYONE WHO
ENGAGES IN ANY COMMERCIAL
FINANCIAL ACTIVITY NO MATTER
HOW SMALL. IS THAT TRUE. NO
SMELL IN REGISTERING AND
SUPERVISING YOU COVERED PERSONS
AS AS PART OF THE PROCESS WE
WOULD WEIGH THE STATE'S
INTEREST IN OVERSIGHT AGAINST
THE RISK OF WORLD OKAY OKAY SO
HOW DO I KNOW IF I'M A COVERED
PERSON OR NOT. IF YOU HAVEN'T
PROMULGATED REGULATIONS YET AS
TO WHOSE CAR WHO WHO IS A
COVERED PERSON. LET ME JUST AS
AN EXAMPLE HI A LOAN MONEY TO
MY NEIGHBOR. I MAY EVEN HAVE AN
MO YOU BECAUSE MY ACCOUNT AND
ASKED ME TO DO THAT THAT'S NOW
FINANCIAL TRANSACTION PERHAPS
EVEN COMMERCIAL THEY MIGHT NOW
COVERED PERSON. HE WOULD HAVE
TO FOLLOW THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT ENSURE THAT
POTENTIAL REGISTRANTS NO THAT
KNOW WHO THEY ARE AND WHAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED. OKAY BUT YET
IN THIS TRAILER BILL YOU ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO HAND FORSMAN
POWER BEFORE THOSE REGULATIONS
ARE PROMULGATED. WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN WE WOULD HAVE THE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY TO
PROHIBIT UNFAIR DECEPTIVE. AND
ABUSIVE ACTS AND PRACTICES
ASKED YOU ASKED THE COVERED
PERSONS OKAY ALL RIGHT. SO LET
ME GET TO MY POINT HERE BECAUSE
OF ONE I DON'T WANT THAT. SO MY
CONCERN IS THAT WHILE I
CERTAINLY- FIRST OF ALL. I
APPRECIATE WHAT SENATOR RAZA
SAID ALL RIGHT BECAUSE WE HAVE
A PANDEMIC- AND I UNDERSTAND
YOUR ANSWERS WELL I MEAN. THERE
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PREDATION. IT'S GOING ON BUT
I'M ALSO VERY CONCERNED THAT
THAT THIS PROPOSAL HAS NOT BEEN
VERY WELL THOUGHT OUT. AND SO
WHAT HAPPENS IS AND THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH BAND WITH INDIAN
MINISTRATION TO FIGURE THIS ALL
OUT GIVEN THE STATE IT'S IN
FRONT OF US. IN FACT I WOULD
ARGUE. THAT IF PREDATION IS AND
I'M NOT DISPUTING THAT THAT
COULD BE AN ISSUE THAT PERHAPS
THE GOVERNOR OUT CON
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION SO WE
ACTUALLY OF THE TIME TO WORK
THROUGH THIS. FRANKLY YOU KNOW
THIS TRYING TO DO THIS IN THE
LAST MINUTE WITHOUT THINKING
THESE THINGS OUT I JUST
PURCHASED A VERY SIMPLE
QUESTION AS A FOLLOW UP TO A
QUESTION MY COLLEAGUE. YOU
REALLY COULDN'T ANSWER CLEARLY.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TELL
PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT AT THE VOTING
ON. IF YOU ASK ME TO VOTE ON
THIS I THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM
SO PERHAPS THE PANEL CAN HELP
CLARIFY BUT I ALSO THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE A MUCH. CLEARER
AND BETTER DEFINED PROPOSAL
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
ESPECIALLY ON THIS MAGNITUDE.
I'M NOT DISPUTING THE ISSUE OF
THE PROBLEM BEFORE WE SHOULD BE.
TO HAVE TO PASS IT I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE IS. AS AS YOU'VE
NOTED BEFORE THAT EVEN THOUGH
YOU HAVE TO SCOUR UNDER DODD
FRANK THAT THE STATE APPARENTLY
I'M NOT SAYING THAT MAYBE IT
WAS EXPENSIVE ENOUGH BUT- DODD
FRANK APPARENTLY. IT WAS NEVER
REQUIRES. AT LEAST A STATE
NEVER PURSUED IT. SO THAT ALSO
AGAIN DEFINES EXACTLY WHAT THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM IS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
AMERICAN TO GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED TO OUR PANEL. IF ANY
MEMBERS I HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AFTER THE PANEL WILL
CERTAINLY- BE ABLE TO ENTERTAIN
THEM AS WELL WE'RE GOING TO GET
STARTED WITH OUR FIRST
PANELISTS. MISTER RICHARD
CORDRAY FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
BUREAU. WHO WILL BE FOLLOWED BY
MISS STROKE BALA. REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA REINVESTMENT
COALITION THEN KEVIN GOULD
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
AND SCOTT GOVERNOR CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL SERVICES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THEM TODAY MR
CORDRAY. THANK YOU MANAGER
UNDERSTANDS THE COMBINED
REMARKS FOUR MINUTES IS THAT
CORRECT. YES SIR THANK YOU OKAY.
IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
BEYOND YOUR PREPARED REMARKS
ARE IN RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS YOU ARE HEARD YOU CAN
FEEL FREE TO ADD THOSE. THANK
YOU. SURE MITCHELL SURE
BRADFORD AND SENATORS THIS IS
RICHARD CORDRAY FOR SIX YEARS I
SERVED AS THE FIRST DIRECTOR OF
THE FEDERAL CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU. AND BEFORE
THAT AS A HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS YOU WANT.
IT RESPECTFULLY AND WITH A
SENSE OF URGENCY INFORMED BY MY
EXPERIENCE AS WE WORK THROUGH
THE LAST ECONOMIC CRISIS. IS
SUPPORTED VIDEO TRAILER BILL TO
STRENGTHEN THE STATE FINANCIAL
OVERSIGHT. IT WILL PROVIDE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WITHOUT USE OF
GENERAL FUND MONIES THE
PROTECTION THEY NEED TO PREVENT
CREDITORS FROM SWINDLING THEM
WHEN THEY CAN LEAST AFFORD IT.
THIS MEASURES DESIGNED TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS SMALL
BUSINESSES NONPROFITS AND
FAMILY FARMS AND TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
FOR ALL PROVIDERS OF FINANCIAL
SERVICES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS WE HAVE HEARD
OVER THE PAST YEAR MANY
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES ARE
CRYING OUT FOR MORE OVERSIGHT
OF UNREGULATED BUSINESSES.
CURRENTLY CAN UNDERCUT THEM IN
THE MARKET PLACE. INCLUDING THE
STATE'S FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT IS
AN URGENT MATTER IN THE FACE OF
WIDESPREAD AND- DISTRESS
METRAGE. DROWSINESS SENATOR
SENIOR POINTS. AT ISSUE.
CALIFORNIA WAS HIT EXTREMELY
HARD BY THE FINANCIAL CRISIS
AND GREAT RECESSION TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. COMMUNITIES
YOUR COMMUNITIES WERE ROCKED BY
FORECLOSURE PEOPLE LOST THEIR
HOMES MANY WONDERED HOW.
PEOPLE'S LIVES WERE DESTROYED
IN CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET WAS
UPSIDE DOWN FOR YEARS IT'S
WIDESPREAD UNEMPLOYMENT
FORECLOSURES. STRAIN THE
STATE'S RESOURCE OF. THE SAME
KIND OF ECONOMIC CRISIS IS NOW
PRESSING DOWN ON CALIFORNIA A.
AS WE'RE SEEING TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE. FINANCIAL CREDITORS
ARE COMING OUT OF THE WOODWORK
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF DESPERATE
CONSUME. CONSUMER THANKS ABOUT
THEM REACHING RECORD LEVELS
NEVER SEEN BEFORE. IF
CALIFORNIA FAILS TO ACT
IMMEDIATELY WE KNOW MORE PEOPLE
LOSE THEIR HOMES AND LIFE
SAVINGS. CREDIT AND ACCESS TO
CAPITAL WILL BE DESTROYED. MANY
WILL NEVER EVER RECOVER. CHIEF
KEEF OF THE- IMPACT THE NEW
ELSE YOU ASKED ABOUT THE WITH
THIS. FIRST IT IS NOT DRAWN ANY
GENERAL FUND REVENUES BUT ONLY
SPECIAL FUNDS WITHIN DVO CANNOT
BE BROUGHT TO BEAR ON THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY. SECOND
OF PUTS IN PLACE THE MEASURES
NEEDED TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES FROM FALLING OFF THE
EDGE INTO FINANCIAL RUIN. THOSE
FAMILIES WHICH SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO RESORT TO STATE SIX SAFE
ENOUGH PROGRAMS WILL HAVE NO
OTHER CHOICE AND THEIR NEED FOR
FURTHER PRESSURING CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGETARY RESOURCES. DELAYED
ACTION MEANS LONG TERM DAMAGE
TO COMMUNITIES THAT ARE UNDER
GREAT PRESSURE RIGHT NOW.
FURTHER STRAINING THE STATE
SOURCES DURING THE MINING
EFFORTS TOWARD ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. PAST SEVEN MONTHS
THERE'S BEEN MUCH AND FORTH
AMONG STATE. OF THE TRAILER
BILL. THREE POINT STAND OUT.
FIRST THERE'S BROADSUPPORT FOR
BRINGING I'M LICENSED AND
REGISTERED FINANCIAL WRITERS
UNDER THE SAME REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT IS EXISTING.
LICENSEES THESE ARE THE COVERED
PERSONS TO FIND IN THE TRAILER
BILL YOU'RE ASKED ABOUT SENATOR
NELSON. IT'S GROSSLY UNFAIR TO
CALIFORNIA'S MANY BANKS AND
CREDIT UNIONS AND OTHER
EXISTING LICENSEES TO HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE OF COMPANIES. THAT
DON'T HAVE TO MEET THE SAME
STANDARD. THIS PROPOSAL PUTS
EVERYBODY ON THE SAME LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD WHICH IS GOOD FOR
CONSUMERS AND RESPONSIBLE
BUSINESSES ALIKE. SECOND
CALIFORNIA CANNOT AND SHOULD
NOT WALK AWAY FROM THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO STAND ON ITS OWN
TWO FEET. AND MODERNIZE ITS
FRAMEWORK FOR PROTECTING
CONSUMERS SOME SUGGEST WE
SHOULD LEAVE IT TO THE PROGRAM
IN WASHINGTON WE SEEM TO SEE IF
HE COULD RETREAT DRAMATICALLY
WHO HAS RESPONSIBILITY. FOR
THIS REASON FEDERAL ON BITES
STATES TO TAKE ON MORE OF A
ROLE IN OVERSEEING FINANCIAL
PROVIDERS AND THE TRAILER BILL
EXCEPT THAT IN THE H. S. FOR
EXISTING LICENSEES. IN THIS
CASE THE QUESTION SENATOR
BRADFORD ROTH AND SKINNER
TOUCHED ON. THE PROPOSAL UNDER
DISCUSSION IS TO LARGELY HOLD
THEM HARMLESS AS LONG AS THE
APPROPRIATE PROCESSES PUT IN
PLACE TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
TO PROVIDE REFUNDS. CONSUMERS
TO HAVE MONEY WRONGLY TAKEN
FROM THE- ATHLETE. THIRD THE
TRAILER BILL INCLUDES BROAD
RANGE OF CONSUMER INSTEAD OF
GROUPS AND LOCAL OFFICIALS THIS
WHO FEEL THE NEED AND ARE
ASKING FOR URGENT BUT IT ALSO
AN COALITIONS BUSINESSES WHO
HAVE OFTEN BEEN AND MARKET
PLACE AND WE'RE SEEKING THE
SAME AS CONSUMERS UNDER
AFFORDABLE WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
CONSUMER FRIENDLY INNOVATIONS
THEY'RE DEMANDING ACTION THEY
DESERVE SUCH PROTECTION AND
WOULD HELP STRENGTHEN
CALIFORNIA. PLEAS REASONS
BECAUSE IN THE NEW URGENCY TO
DISTRESSED FAMILIES OUR
FEELINGS ARE BEING HAMMERED IN
THE CURRENT ECONOMIC CRISIS
ADOPTION OF THE TRAILER BILL
WOULD HELP CALIFORNIA REPORTED
NEARLY GET FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES ACTION FIGURES-
SURE MITCHELL SURE BRADFORD
SENATORS RIGHT NOW MANY
SOPHISTICATED BUSINESSES
LOOKING TO GET RICH BY MAKING
YOUR CONSTITUENTS OR PLEASE
DON'T LET WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE.
HAPPEN AGAIN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISSPELLED. CALIFORNIA
REINVESTS COALITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON TEARS MITCHELL AND
BRADFORD AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES I'M JOKES FOR BAJA
CALIFORNIA REINVESTMENT
COALITION WE REPRESENT THREE
HUNDRED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
AND IN BOTH URBAN AND RURAL
AREAS. AND AS YOU KNOW THE
DEPTH OF THE CULTURE CRISIS ARE
RAPIDLY ECLIPSING WHAT WE
SIGNED TWO THOUSAND EIGHT ONE
OF THE MOST DEVASTATING
LEGACIES OF THAT CRISIS IS THAT
IT WAS ONE OF THE LARGEST
TRANSFERS OF WEALTH IN THE
COUNTRY'S ISTORY AND THAT
WEALTH LOSS WAS EXPERIENCED
MOST GREATLY IN BOOKS BLACK AND
LATINO COMMUNITIES AS YOU ALSO
KNOW THIS TRANSFER OF WILD
HAPPENS MOST PROMINENTLY WHEN
LOSE THEIR BUSINESSES AND WHEN
THEY LOSE THEIR HOMES. IN
RESPONSE CFPB WAS CREATED BACK
THEN AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND
AS MANY AS THEY MOVE AWAY FROM
THEIR ORIGINAL MISSION SMALL
BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS ARE
SUFFERING A STATE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION CAN BE INSTRUMENTAL
IN PROTECTING HISTORICALLY
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES
FROM EXPERIENCING WHILE LOST HE
DIDLEAVE THE COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE FACED STRUCTURAL BARRIERS
TO BUILD WEALTH TO BEGIN WITH
CAN BE PROTECTED FROM HAVING TO
START ALL OVER WITH EACH CRISIS
BY OUR ACTIONS. FIRST ALL
ADDRESS A SMALL BUSINESS MEANS
THE DATA'S OUT ITS BLACK AND
LATINOS WHO ARE LOSING THEIR
ONCE PROFITABLE BUSINESSES NOW
ALL OF THE DATA THAT IS
AVAILABLE REGARDING THE PPP
LOANS ONLY 2% OF THE RECIPIENTS
BOTH BUSINESSES AND ONLY 6%
WERE LATINOS THIS IS DUE TO
THE- ACTUAL. COMBAT IT BANK
EVEN TODAY IN RESPONSE TO THIS
JUST WEEKS AFTER IN APRIL THIS
YEAR JUST WEEKS AFTER THE
SHUTDOWN WE SURVEYED OUR MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS AND ALREADY MANY
WERE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
UNFAIR DECEPTIVE LENDING
LENDERS WHO OPERATE WITH
IMPUNITY OUR MEMBERS WERE
WORRIED BECAUSE THEY HAVE SEEN
THIS BEFORE OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE LITTLE TO NO ACCESS TO SAY
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS DUE TO
DISCRIMINATION IN LENDING MUCH
LIKE WHAT WE SAW WITH THE
ROLLOUT OF THE PPP. SO OUR
COMMUNITIES. TRYING TO MERCHANT
CASH ADVANCE OUTSIDE ONCE.
BUSINESSES BUSINESS OWNERS. THE
PREDATOR NATURE THE LOAN. THEY
BACK FOR. REFINANCE BUT OFTEN
IT'S TOO LATE AND- HAVE SMALL
BUSINESSES. LEAVE SMALL
BUSINESSES STOCK WITH HIGH
INTEREST RATES AND HIDDEN FEES.
LEADING TO PAINFUL APR LEVELS
AND MANY MAKE YOU SIGN A WAIVER
ALLOWING THEM TO SEIZE YOUR
ASSETS WITHOUT WARNING. JUST
THIS MONTH WE HAVE OUR MEMBERS
CALLING TO TROUBLESHOOT HOW TO
SAVE A BIG RESTAURANT IN SAN
FRANCISCO. DON RAMON'S A
LANDMARK RESTAURANT IS
CURRENTLY FIGHTING TO KEEP
THEIR BUILDINGS ARE BEING SOLD
AT AUCTION IN THIRTEEN DAYS
FROM TODAY. GHALI TOOK OUT OF
WHAT TURNED OUT TO BE A
PREDATORY LOAN. FOR THE SAKE OF
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES LIKE
DON RAMON'S REVAMPING THE DVO
INTO ON THIS NEW MISSION DRIVEN
CONSUMER FACING AGENCY AS THE
DS PAI IS URGENTLY NEEDED THIS
YEAR. SO THAT THESE BUSINESSES
CAN CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND HANG
ON TO THEIR WEALTH. NOW ABOUT
THE HOMES. CALIFORNIA MUST
ENSURE WE DON'T REPEAT MISTAKES
MADE DURING THE FORECLOSURE
CRISIS IN ALLOWING LARGE
CORPORATE LANDLORDS PRIVATE
EQUITY AND OTHER SPECULATORS
GOBBLE UP DISTRESSED PROPERTIES
AND FUEL ANOTHER WAVE OF
DISPLACEMENT OF THE STATE'S
WORKING FAMILIES COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND SMALL BUSINESSES. WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE STATE
ADOPTED ANTI DISPLACEMENT CODE
OF CONDUCT POLICY THAT TOGETHER
WITH THE REVAMPS DPO COULD
ENSURE THAT LENDERS TO THE
FOLLOWING SOME OF THE
FOLLOWING. HAVE AN EQUITABLE
APPROACH TO A SUCCESSFULLY
OFFERING JUST RE FINANCING TO
HOMEOWNERS EXPERIENCING WAGE
LOSSES AT TIMES LIKE THESE. AND
IN CASE OF MULTI FAMILY OR
MIXED USE BUILDINGS UNDERWRITE
LOANS BASED ON RENTS THAT
CURRENT RESIDENTIAL NONPROFIT
AND BUSINESS TENANTS ARE PAYING
NOT INCREASED RIGHT. CLEAN OUT
OF BORROWER LANDLORDS THAT HAVE
A BUSINESS MODEL OF DISPLAYS
ARE DISPLACING TENANTS DOES
EXIST WE CALL THOSE LANDLORDS
YOUR ELECTORS. WE EXPECT THE
PANDEMIC TO CONTINUE TO DISRUPT
OUR LIVES FOR SOMETIME IF WE
FAIL TO ACT NOW WE MAY CREATE A
VICIOUS CYCLE IN WHICH
UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS GO UN
CHECKED AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
CONSUMERS AND SMALL BUSINESSES
WHO TURN COULD FALL FURTHER
BEHIND AND BE UNABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR EVENTUAL
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. A NEW D. S.
P. I CAN ENSURE THAT LENDERS
SUPPORT COMMUNITIES IN A WAY
THAT ALLOWS ALL TO PROSPER WE
ARE READY TO WORK WITH YOU THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
MAKE THIS A REALITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
GOULD CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION. BETTER CHAIR
MISTER CHAIR SENATORS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
OUR PERSPECTIVE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
REORGANIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION I
WANT TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO MEET WITH
US AND OUR WILLINGNESS TO
EXPLORE SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
WITH THE COMMISSIONER AND HIS
TEAM. WE APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT'S EMPHASIS ON
INNOVATION AND WE HOPE THESE
EFFORTS WILL PROMOTE THE
SUCCESS OF ITS LICENSEES. AND
SERVE AS A CATALYST TO RETAIN
AND GROW THE NUMBER OF
LICENSEES. PARTICULARLY GIVEN
CONTINUED CONSOLIDATION IN THE
BANKING INDUSTRY. TO UNDERSCORE
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS MISSION
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THERE
WERE TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
STATE CHARTERED BANKS COMPARED
TO ONE HUNDRED AND TWELVE STATE
CHARTERED BANKS TODAY. IT'S R.
O. THE DEPARTMENT WILL IDENTIFY
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO ENCOURAGE
NEW BANKS FORMATIONS WHICH IS
VITAL IN ENSURING THE ECONOMIC
SUCCESS OF OUR STATE. IN THAT
COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL SERVICES. WE APPLAUD
THE GOVERNOR'S DESIRE TO
PROVIDE A REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
AND SUPERVISION FOR UNREGULATED
ENTITIES. THEY'RE OFFERING
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS OR SERVICES
IF DONE CORRECTLY SUCH AN
APPROACH WOULD ENSURE GREATER
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD AMONG THOSE
PROVIDING FINANCIAL PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTIFIED WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THIS PROPOSALS. BE
NARROWED TO FOCUS SOLELY ON ON
REGULATED ENTITIES AND THAT
LICENSED ENTITIES BE EXEMPT
FROM THE ENTIRETY OF THE
PROPOSAL. IN FACT THERE'S
PRECEDENT FOR WHAT WE ARE
REQUESTING IN THIS VERY TRAILER
BILL. THE VERY EXEMPTION WE ARE
REQUESTING HAS ALREADY BEEN
GRANTED THE LICENSEES OF EVERY
OTHER STATE AGENCY OR
DEPARTMENT. SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE. THIS
CAN BE FOUND IN SECTION NINE
ZERO ZERO ZERO TWO SUBDIVISION
A- WE'RE ASKING FOR THE SAME
TREATMENT THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
PROVIDED TO LICENSEES OF OTHER
STATE AGENCIES AND WE'RE EVEN
WILLING TO UNDERSCORE THE FACT
THAT NOTHING IN THE EXEMPTION
WOULD ALTER. THE STATE'S
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY THAT IS
PRESENTLY AVAILABLE UNDER DODD
FRANK. TO FURTHER OUR REQUEST
LICENSE ENTITIES BE EXEMPT FROM
THE PROPOSAL BANKS ARE ALREADY
SUBJECT TO LICENSING AND ARE
SUPERVISED BY MULTIPLE
REGULATORS. STATE CHARTERED
BANKS ARE LICENSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT AND SUBJECT AT A
MINIMUM TO ADDITIONAL
SUPERVISION BY THE FEDERAL
DEPOSIT INSURANCE CORPORATION.
AND THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU. WELL
FEDERALLY CHARTERED BANKS ARE
LICENSED BY THE OFFICE OF THE
COMPTROLLER OF THE CURRENCY AND
SUBJECT AT A MINIMUM TO
ADDITIONAL SUPERVISION BY THE
FDIC AND CFPB. IN ORDER FOR A
BANK TO SECURE A LICENSE THEY
MUST PROVE TO THE DEPARTMENT
THAT THEY'RE WORTHY OF
RECEIVING THAT LICENSE. THROUGH
A BUSINESS PLAN COMPLETE AN
EXTENSIVE APPLICATION GATHERING
THE CAPITAL NECESSARY FOR
FORMATION AND DEMONSTRATING
THAT THEY HAVE A REASONABLE
CHANCE OF SUCCESS. RATES ARE
SUBJECT TO FREQUENT AUDITS AND
EXAMS WHERE THEY MUST PROVE
THAT THEY OPERATE IN A SAFE AND
SOUND MANNER. ADEQUATE CAPITAL
TO WHETHER ECONOMIC SHOCKS
THEIR ASSET QUALITY IS HIGH
THEIR MANAGEMENT TEAM QUALIFIED
THEY CAN PRODUCE EARNINGS CAN
DEMONSTRATE LIQUIDITY TO PAY
THEIR DEPOSITORS. AND HAVE A
SYSTEM IN SPIN PLACE TO BE
SENSITIVE TO CHANGING INTEREST
RATE ENVIRONMENTS. THANKS ARE
SUBJECT TO PERIODIC AUDIT AND
EXAMINATION BY THE DEPARTMENT
WHICH GIVES A REGULATOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO IDENTIFY
EMERGING ISSUES AND TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION EARLY. THESE
ON SITE EXAMINATIONS INCLUDE
EXTENSIVE PRE ENTRY LETTERS
REQUIRED THE GATHERING OF
EXTENSIVE DOCUMENTATION AND
DEPARTMENT EXAM STAFF.
PHYSICALLY PRESENT ON A BANK
PROPERTY FOR MULTIPLE DAYS.
LICENSING PROVISIONS IN CURRENT
LOG AROUND REGULATORS WITH
ROBUST ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY
INCLUDING CEASE AND DESIST
ORDERS AGAINST PERSONS AND
INSTITUTIONS SIXTEEN BUSINESS
ACTIVITIES SUSPENDING OR
REMOVING PERSONS OR PROHIBITING
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THE
FUTURE WITH AN INSTITUTION.
REVOKING OR SUSPENDING A
LICENSE AND TAKING POSSESSION
OF THE PROPERTY AND BUSINESS OF
THE LICENSEE. ON TOP OF ALL OF
THIS THE STATE HAS AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE PROVISIONS OF TITLE TEN
OF DODD FRANK FOR WHICH THIS
PROPOSAL RESEMBLES. WE HEARD
EARLIER IN THE TESTIMONY THAT
THEY WERE ADEQUATE TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE BELIEVE THE EXEMPTION MAKES
SENSE. IN SUMMARY WE BELIEVE
THAT ENHANCE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ALREADY EXIST
WITHIN THE LICENSE COMMUNITY.
ARE OVERSIGHT IS ROBUST AND
MULTIFACETED AND THE
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
OUR REGULATORS IS NOT LACKING
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OF
LICENSED ENTITIES BE EXEMPT. IF
THIS PROPOSAL IS TO MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU WITH THE GOLD
AND NOW WE HEAR FROM OUR FINAL
A WITNESS IN THE THIS PANEL-
MISTER GOVERNOR CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL SERVICES ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MATTER
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE COMMISSIONER AND HIS TEAM.
FOR PROVIDING US AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE US CERTAINLY MY CLIENT
CONCURS WITH THE SENTIMENTS OF
MISTER GOLDMAN CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION. ALTHOUGH
AS A NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE REYES TODAY I ALSO
HAPPEN TO READ REPRESENT PEOPLE
WHO WOULD BE REGISTRANTS HE AND
THE LACK OF CLARITY IN THE
PROPOSAL IS VERY TROUBLING. AS
THE L. A. L. NOTED THIS DOES
SEATED A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
FORTY TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BRANCH. AS SUCH WE THINK THE
LANGUAGE AROUND REGULATION
SHOULD BE CLARIFIED.
SPECIFICALLY THROUGHOUT THE
BILL IT PROVIDES THAT D. FBI
MAY PROMULGATE REGULATIONS
CONCERNING REGISTRATION. MAY
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS
CONCERNING DISCLOSURE. RECORDS
RETENTION- AND ON AND ON AND
ON. FRANKLY I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW THE REGULATED COMMUNITY-
REGISTRANTS CAN ADHERE TO RULES
THAT THEY DON'T KNOW EXIST.
THIS IS EASILY RECTIFIED IF THE
WORD MAY IS REPLACED WITH SHALL
THROUGHOUT THE PROPOSAL AT
LEAST THEN. THE REGULATE
COMMUNITY WOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON THE
PROCESS AND AT LEAST UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY ARE SUBJECT. TO
SOMETHING THAT SENATOR COUNTY
RAISED. HAD TO DO WITH THE
NUMBERS OF GROUPS INVOLVED-
THERE IS ACTUALLY ONE
ADDITIONAL GROUP OF IRAQIS TO
BE COVERED BY THIS BILL. AND
THAT ARE THAT IS COMPANIES OR
ENTITIES WHO ARE NOT LICENSED.
BUT WHO ARE REGULATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE- THERE
ARE A HOST OF BACKS FROM THE
CARNEDDAU REESE LEVERING AND
CHECK CASHIER'S. WHO ARE
SUBJECT TO AUTHORITY BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TODAY.
THE CONCERN WE HAVE THE BILL WE
WILL CERTAINLY RAISE THIS WITH-
DPO IS AS DRAFTED. D. O. J.
COULD BRING AN ACTION FOR A
VIOLATION- FROM ONE OF THEIR
REGULATED ENTITIES. THE FBI
COULD THEN BRINGTHE EXACT SAME
CIVIL ACTION ALLEGING THAT YOU
THAT WHILE ISSUE AGAINST THAT
SAME EDUCATE. THIS MEANS THE
ENTITIES ARE ALREADY COVERED BY
EXISTING LAW WHO ARE UNLICENSED
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED- MORE
STRIDENT OVERSIGHT THAT
ENTITIES THAT ARE COMPLETELY
UNREGULATED WE THINK THIS
pTOO AGENCY SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
GO OUT TO THE SAME ENTITY WITH
THE EXACT SAME THING. FINALLY
THERE'S A PROVISION IN THE
GOVERNMENT COAT THAT'S
REFERENCED IN THE BILL THAT
DEALS WITH DUE PROCESS I'M NOT
SURE IF THIS IS A TYPE OR NOT.
BUT THE BILL ONLY REFERENCES
HALF OF THE GOVERNMENT CODE
LEAVES OUT THE DUE PROCESS
PROVISIONS THIS IS EASILY
FIXED. AND THE BILL PROVIDES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT MAY RECOVER
ATTORNEY'S FEES AND COURT
ACTION. IF THEY PREVAIL HOWEVER
IF THEY LOSE THE PARTY THAT
PREVAILED IS NOT ENTITLED TO
ATTORNEYS FEES. WE THINK THIS
IS INEQUITABLE WE ASK THAT THIS
BE. FIXED WE PROVIDE ALL THESE
SUGGESTIONS TO THAT APARTMENT.
AND WITH TWO WEEKS LEFT TO GO
WE'VE NOT HEARD BACK ON THEM.
AND WOULD WELCOME THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE LEGISLATURE
TO RECTIFY THESE PROBLEMS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME WE
APPRECIATE. YOUR EFFORTS AND
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. YOU
ALL ARE OF YOUR SATURDAY
AFTERNOON- BEFORE I OPEN UP TO
THE FLOOR I WOULD JUST SAY THE
MISS- BOTTLE I WAS INTRIGUED BY
YOUR COMMENT ABOUT AN ANTI
DISPLACEMENT CODE OF CONDUCT
AND SO IF YOU COULD. TO SINCE
THEN BACKGROUND MATERIALS TO MY
OFFICE I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT.
QUESTIONS MEMBERS HAVE.
QUESTIONS OF THE PANEL. SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION BY THE PANEL ON
THE DIFFERENT IDEAS AND
CONCEPTS THAT WERE PUT FORTH I
GUESS WHY DON'T. WHERE I DON'T
SEE AND I HOPE THAT WILL HAPPEN
IS SORT OF A CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE PRESS. LEAST WHAT IS IN THE
TRAILER BILL AND SOME OF THESE
IDEAS WHICH I THINK MANY OF
THEM ARE VERY GOOD- SO. AS I
EXPRESSED IN MY EARLIER QUITE
YOU KNOW QUESTIONS WHY I'M
CONCERNED IS THAT WERE BEING
ASKED ARE I KNOW THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WILL
EVENTUALLY BE ASKED TO VOTE ON
A- TRAILER BILL AND I CERTAINLY
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WHETHER THIS
IS REALLY TRAILER BILL VERSUS-
POLICY BILL THAT WE WON'T GET
INTO THAT TOO MUCH WE DO DO. IT
SOMETIMES THINGS HAPPEN BUT BUT
THAT IT'S NOT VETTED WELL
ENOUGH AND IN FACT- THAT WAY I
DON'T WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN IS
BASICALLY A SORT OF A CATCHALL
TRAILER BILL THAT SAYS YOU KNOW
WHAT THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
IDEAS OUT THERE- NO LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. WE EXPECT INDUSTRIES
IS GONNA CARRY THEM OUT AND
HOPE THAT YOU DO THAT. RIGHT I
MEAN I THINK WE NEED TO BE MUCH
MORE SPECIFIC- THERE NEEDS TO
BE MUCH MORE SPECIFICITY ABOUT
WHO WILL FALL UNDER THIS I MEAN
WHEN I POSE THE QUESTION ABOUT.
THE ODD COMMISSIONER REALLY ANY
DANCER I THINK WAS A LITTLE
CONCERNING- THAT NEEDS TO BE
VERY MUCH CLARIFIED WHO FALLS
UNDER THIS BILL WHAT'S THE
SCOPE OF THIS AGENCY- I GET IT
YOU HAVE ON THE OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT LICENSED DAY OF PRIDE
THE DETAILED. OVERSIGHT LORALAI.
WHAT MISSING FOR THERE OVER.
THAT THEIR CURRENT LICENSE
DOESN'T COVER ANY WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE PEOPLE HAVING TO
RESPOND TO. MULTIPLE AGENCIES
WHO WHICH MAY EVEN HAVE GIVE
CONFLICTING GUIDANCE I MEAN
THAT'S AN ISSUE AS WELL THAT.
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY STYMIE OUR
LIMIT POTENTIALLY ACCESS TO
CREDIT THAT PEOPLE CAN GET. AS
WELL- WE ALSO WE ONLY LIKE TO
DISCOURAGE. THAT BEHAVIOR THAT
ISN'T GOOD FOR COMMUNITIES AND
I APPRECIATE SOME OF THOSE
PRESENTATIONS WHICH MAY NOT
STRICTLY BE IN A LENDING
PRACTICES PER SE BUT ALSO BUT
YOU KNOW I'M FIGURE HAVE
INCORPORATE SOME OF THAT- SO I
GUESS WHAT I JUST SAY IS THAT-
CERTAINLY THIS INFORMATION
HEARINGS BEEN RAIN AND
LIGHTNING- BUT- I. YEAH WE HAVE
TO DO THIS RIGHT. AND I
CERTAINLY HEAR THE URGENCY
ISSUE I'M NOT DENYING THE
URGENCY BUT THE URGENCY ALONE
IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO SAY WE'RE
GOING TO PASS. A BETTER POLICY
THAT IS THAT IS NOT WELL
THOUGHT OUT AND IT IT AND
FRANKLY I DO ALSO WANT TO JUST
AGAIN SECOND THE- WHAT SENATOR
RAZA SAID IS THAT IT'S- THE-
OTHER QUESTION IS THERE TO BAN
WITHIN THE- ADMINISTRATION TO
SPEND THE TIME TO DO THIS
RIGHT. AND RECOGNIZING THAT WE
ALSO HAVE OTHER PRIORITIES WERE
DOING NOT SAYING THAT WE CAN'T
DO THIS. BUT I WANT TO SEE A
COMMITMENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO REALLY WORK
THESE THINGS OUT NOT EXPECT THE
LEGISLATURE SIMPLY TO SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA PASS AND
OPEN ENDED ONE AND THEN WE'LL
WE'LL FIGURE OUT LATER WE NEED
TO KNOW THE ANSWERS NOW BEFORE
WE- AS A LEGISLATURE WILL VOTE
ON THIS. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND YOU KNOW I
YES YOU ACKNOWLEDGES IT THIS IS
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING IN THE
POINT OF THE- HELLO IS TO SHARE
PERSPECTIVES AND NOT ONLY
RESPOND TO THE PROPOSAL BEFORE
US BUT TO TALK ABOUT. THEIR
EXPERIENCES PROFESSIONALS IN
THE FIELD IN THE INDUSTRY TO
ENLIGHTEN US ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON OUT. IN THE STATE'S GOING TO
BE ON OUR OWN KNOWLEDGE BASE IN
OUR OWN DISTRICTS. SO IT'S A
IT'S A TWO FOR IF YOU WILL DR
PAM. CENTER WHERE CAL SKI. FOR
A QUESTION FOR TRACTOR. INJURY
BECAUSE HE MAY BE IN A UNIQUE.
HER THE POSITION LECH'S
PRETENDED A BIDEN HERIS TICKET
PASSES AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
ROBUST FEDERAL CONSUMER
PROTECTION AGENCY M. WE ADOPT
THIS. REGULATION AND WE HAVE A
REAL BUS STATE CONSUMER
PROTECTION AGENCY HOW CAN YOU
SPEAK TO AT LEAST FOR THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY THAT
THEY'RE NOT CAUGHT BETWEEN THE
CROSSFIRE OF THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS TRYING TO.
ONE UP EACH OTHER WITH REGARD
TO TRYING TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
SERVICES AND CONDUCT BUSINESS
IN THIS ARENA. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ONE POINT. IS THE ONE
I MADE BEFORE WHICH IS THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
DEPEND ON WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
WASHINGTON IS THE WEATHER
CALIFORNIANS GIVE PROTECTION
AGAINST FINANCIAL ABUSE AND THE
POINT THAT WAS MADE EARLIER BY
THE QUESTIONS. FROM SENATOR RON
AND OTHERS WAS THAT THE FEDERAL
LAW HAD NOT BEEN USED BY THE
CALIFORNIA AGENCY YEAH I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF TO BE EXPECTED
IT'S NOT A NATURAL THING FOR A
STATE AGENCY TO TRY TO ENFORCE
FEDERAL LAW AND TRY TO CRAM IT
INTO EXISTING STATE LICENSE
ACTIONS AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY A CLEARLY SUBJECT
THE CALIFORNIA EIGHTY A THE KEY
HERE IS TO GET THIS PROTECTION
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE LAW.
THE DEPARTMENT KNOWS VERY WELL
HOW IT CAN WORK WITH THAT IT
KNOWS THE PROPER PROCESSES IN
LICENSE ACTIONS IT IS SUBJECT
TO CALIFORNIA'S DUE PROCESS
PROVISION THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND ALSO WITH THE
EIGHTY EIGHT SO THAT'S
IMPORTANT THE OTHER POINT I
WOULD MAKE IS WHEN I WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FEDERAL CFPB
AND WE WERE MORE AGGRESSIVE
CLEARLY THEN THE CFPB HAS BEEN
IT'S ALMOST BEEN PARALYZED IN
TERMS OF ENFORCING THE LAW. WE
KNEW WE COULDN'T POSSIBLY ASK
ALL THE CONCERNS AND ISSUES
THAT WOULD BEING RAISED IN A
STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA WE DIDN'T
KNOW THE LOCAL COMMUNITY AS
WELL WE WOULD SOMETIMES GET
REFERRALS AND THINGS AND WE
WOULD ACT. THE BEST SITUATION
IS TO HAVE A REAL PARTNERSHIP
WITH. OFFICIALS ARE OUT FOR
CALIFORNIA. FOR NOT HAVING TO
ON WHAT HOW IN WASHINGTON DC
BUT IF THERE IS APPETITE AND-
DC TO WERE WITH THEM. BUT
THERE'S JOIN EFFORTS AND
COOPERATION COOPERATIVE
FEDERALISM WHICH IS WHAT THE
DODD FRANK ACT. PROVIDED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO ACCEPT
THIS INVITATION IN ORDER TO
MAKE THAT REAL AND FRANKLY
NEEDS TO ACCEPT IT NOW BECAUSE
IF YOU PUT THIS FACT INTO
ANOTHER PROCESS. IT'LL BE
ANOTHER YEAR AND THEN ANOTHER
YEAR AFTER THAT BEFORE IT
BECOMES LAW YOU'RE GONNA MISS
THIS WHOLE CRISIS ALTOGETHER.
THAT WOULD BE A TRAGEDY FOR
CALIFORNIANS BUT I THINK
THEY'RE BEING. AYE HAMBURGERS
AYE SAID RIGHT NOW. READING
AUTHORED FORECASTING THANKS
GREAT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS. ANYMORE IT LASTED FOR.
SENATOR CABALLERO I KNOW YOU
HAD SOME REMARKS YOU WANT TO
MAKE AFTER THE PANEL CONCLUDED.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY A FEW THINGS THAT I WANTED
TO WAIT TILL AFTER THE PANEL
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BECAUSE I WANTED TO HEAR WITH
THE PANEL HAD TO SAY. AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND I
UNDERSTAND- THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN REGARDS TO-
THE NEED TO PROTECT THE
COMMUNITY THERE'S NO QUESTION I
MEAN THAT THAT IN MY MIND AT
EASE AND QUESTIONED ITS IT'S
REALLY WHAT. WHAT D. B. O.'S
CORE MISSION IS IN AND IN FACT
ALL OF THE REGULATORY AGENCIES
THAT LOCAL OVERLOOK LICENSEES
IN THAT THAT- THAT DO HEIR
ENFORCEMENT MY CONCERN IS THIS
AND I. AND I GUESS. THERE'S A
WOULD TO ME THERE'S THIS
DISCONNECT. I'M ASSUMING WE
PASS THIS. TODAY WHENEVER WE
FINALLY GET IT FOR A VOTE ON
THE FIRST YEAR IS IT IS A IS A
SKELETAL COMPOSITION IS WHAT I
HEARD AND- AND SO TO THINK THAT
THIS BILL OR THIS TRAILER BILL
WILL ACTUALLY START IMPACTING.
THE UNREGULATED UNLICENSED
ENTITIES THAT ARE ACTING RIGHT
NOW I JUST THINK IT'S
UNREALISTIC I DON'T I DON'T SEE
IT HAPPENING IN AND MAYBE I'M
I'M WRONG BUT- BUT I UNDERSTAND
HOW THE REGULATORY PROCESS
WORKS HAVING. SUPERVISED THAT
BEFORE AND IT TAKES A WHILE TO
ON. IT TAKES A WHILE BASICALLY
TO HIRE STAFF TO GET HIM
TRAINED TO GET HIM WORKING
TOGETHER TO GET THE REGULATIONS
IN ORDER. AND THEN TO START
DOING THAT THE OVERSIGHT THAT'S
NEEDED THAT'S NOT TO SAY IT'S
NOT NEEDED. RIGHT NOW I'M JUST
SAYING THAT THAT I DON'T SEE I
DON'T SEE IT HAPPENING AND SO
PART OF THE CHALLENGE THAT I
HAVE IS I THOUGHT THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE ASKED TODAY WERE
EXCELLENT I. I HAD A I'VE GOT
I'VE GOT A BUNCH AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF A MORE ASKED BY
SOMEONE ELSE AND SO THE
CHALLENGE FOR ME IS PROCESS. IS
THAT I'M VERY CONCERNED THAT
THE WAY THAT WE STAND UP A
REORGANIZATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT BOB IS USUALLY TWO
FOLD ONE IS IT'S THROUGH THE
BUDGET I MEAN THROUGH THE- A
BILLPROCESS YOU GET SOME
LEGISLATOR TO KERRY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BILL AND TO
TAKE IT TO THE POLICY
COMMITTEES. OR YOU TAKE UP THE
PROCESS THAT IS WRITTEN. I
BELIEVE IT'S IN THE
CONSTITUTION THE TAKE YOU TAKE
IT THROUGH THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION AND WHAT YOU DO IS
YOU HAVE A BUSINESS PLAN AND
THE BUT THE BUSINESS PLAN
ARTICULATES EXACTLY WHAT IT IS
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
WITH A REORGANIZATION. IT GOES
THROUGH THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION THEY HOLD HEARINGS
AND THEN THAT PLAN COMES TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE EITHER GIVE
IT THE THUMBS UP OR THE THUMBS
DOWN WE CAN'T CHANGE IT WE
CAN'T AMENDED. ON IT IT IT IT
IT EXISTS AS AS IT TOO IT WAS
WRITTEN BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AND NEITHER OF THOSE WORDS WERE
DOWN HERE AND THAT. THOSE
PROCESSES GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR THIS CAN
THIS IN COMMITTEE AND REALLY
HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF WHO ARE WE
TRYING TO REGULATE. IT OR THE
REGULATION WHAT'S THE FRAMEWORK
FOR THE REGULATION WHO'S GOING
TO DO IT HOW DID IT HOW IS IT
GOING TO HAPPEN AND THEN WHAT
IS IT GOING TO COST AND THAT
HASN'T THAT HASN'T HAPPENED
WE'VE WE'VE TRIED TO DO IT.
BACKWARDS BY SAYING HERE'S A
BUDGET HERE'S WHAT IT'S GOING
TO COST AND TRUST US WE CAN WE
CAN GET OUT THERE AND AN
APPROPRIATELY. REGULATE THESE
ENTITIES AND I'M NOT SURE I
HAVE A REAL GOOD SAID OF. WHO
WOULD BE REGULATED. OTHER THAN
I'M LICENSED AND UNREGULATED.
AND THEN WHAT WOULD BE THE
FRAMEWORK FOR REGULATING THEM
AND HOW DO WE EVALUATE- THAT
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE. AND
QUITE FRANKLY I. I HAVE NO
DOUBT THAT THERE IS CONSUMER
DISTRESS. BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF MONEY RIGHT NOW. AND THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT
WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
SITUATION I GET REGULAR CALLS
ON THE PHONE. THAT TELL ME THAT
I AM BEING INVESTIGATED BY THE
IRS AND THEN I BETTER SENT YET.
GET UP GET A CALL IMMEDIATELY
pWRITTEN AND- AND IT'S BECOME
MORE APPARENT THE OLDER I GET
RIGHT BECAUSE IF THEY'RE
PREYING ON ON SENIORS. SO
ANYWAY I JUST I HAVE A- WE'LL
SEE WHERE THIS GOES IN THE END
BUT I HAVE A REAL PROBLEM WITH
TRYING TO DO THIS THROUGH A
BUDGET PROCESS AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE. I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT I APPRECIATE. ON THE
COMMISSIONER AND ALL THE WORK
THAT HE'S DONE. BECAUSE HE'S
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH. MY OFFICE
AND ME AND NUMBER OF TIMES AND
WE'VE TALKED THROUGH A NUMBER
OF THESE ISSUES A CHEST. IT'S
JUST THAT THIS IS A DIFFICULT
PROCESS TO USE TO GET. TO GET
TO THE GOAL AND SO I. I DO
THINK THAT THAT- THAT THIS IS.
THAT THE QUESTION THAT A BRICK
BEEN RAZOR REALLY TROUBLING SO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU FOR. AND IN I WOULD ASK-
THE COMMISSIONER TO RESPOND TO
THAT IN ADDITION TO- IN
ADDITION TO CALLS TO YOU AND
OTHER MEMBERS AYE I'M CLEAR
THAT THAT THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND LEGISLATIVE
STAFF. AND SOME YOU KNOW BACK
AND FORTH AS HAPPENED WITH
REGARD TO CONTENT BUT BUT I DO
HAVE A QUESTION IS AS TO
WHETHER ANY ADDITIONAL CHANGES.
ON THE BASE OF THE LANGUAGE WE
HAVE BEFORE US TODAY DO YOU
INTEND TO MAKE. MORE
ADJUSTMENTS TO YOUR TIMELINE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE DO
ANTICIPATE WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF CONSIDERING
ADDITIONAL CHANGES. ON AN
EXPEDITED BASIS WERE- WE ARE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH US-
IN MINISTRATION LEADERSHIP. IN
FACT I- ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL
BE. RECONVENING ARE SOME OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AFTER THIS
HEARING. INTO THE EVENING AND
TOMORROW SO. THE UPSHOT IS YES-
THERE ARE VERY LIKELY TO BE
ADDITIONAL CHANGES AND WE ARE-
UNDERSTANDING- ALL OF THE- ALL
THE VALID CONCERNS ABOUT TIMING
HERE WE'RE OF COURSE- SPRINTING
AS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE-
LOCKSTEP WITH WITH
ADMINISTRATION LEADERSHIP TO.
TO GET. FINAL REVISIONS BACK
OVER TO LEGISLATIVE STAFF
EXCEPT. THANK YOU AND BEFORE I
OPENED IT UP- TO PUBLIC COMMENT
ON WHEN TO GIVE LA- FINANCE OR
THE COMMISSION OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO ANYTHING YOU'VE
HEARD EITHER FROM THAT MEMBERS
QUESTIONS THE PANELISTS. ANY
RESPONSES BEFORE WE OPENED UP
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. YES THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL THIS IS
KIMBERLY HARBISON. FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WE
THANK YOU FOR THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION TODAY AND THERE
ARE A FEW POINTS I JUST WANTED
TO. RESPECTFULLY ADDRESS WE
KNOW THAT THIS HAS BEEN A VERY
UNUSUAL YEAR AND THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
CALENDAR. HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
DISRUPTED BY COVERED BUT WE DID
THE- FIRST PRESENT THIS AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY
THE LANGUAGE HAS BEEN OUT- MANY
MONTHS SINCE JANUARY FEBRUARY.
AND AS AS BEEN NOTED A FEW
TIMES WE HAVE DONE EXTENSIVE.
OUTREACH TO LET STAFF
LEGISLATORS- STAKEHOLDERS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE SO.
ALTHOUGH IT IS COMING DOWN TO
THE END OF THE SESSION WE FEEL
LIKE WE HAVE HAD. YOU KNOW
THOROUGH AND ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS. I'M YOURSELVES
INCLUDED- THERE WAS A QUESTION
ABOUT SB NINE OH EIGHT PASSES
AND IF IT DOES. WE WOULD TAKE
THE CONSIDERATIONS OF WHAT THIS
PROPOSAL COSTS- IF IT PASSES
AND THEN IF SB NINE AWAIT
PASSES. THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
PUT TOGETHER B. C. P. AND THE
NEXT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE COST
DIFFERENCES SO IT WOULDN'T BE A
DUPLICATION OF COST OR EFFORT
BUT IT WOULD FACTOR IN THIS
PROPOSAL AS WELL- AND WE'D LIKE
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
EFFORTS- TO HEAR ALL THIS TODAY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO. DRESS THE
PART ABOUT THE ORGANIZATION WE
DON'T SEE THIS AS A TYPICAL
WE'RE WE ORGANIZATION IT'S MORE
OF A ADDITION TO THE DEPARTMENT
SO I THINK IF WE WEREN'T
CHANGING THE NAME OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT TO FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION THERE
MIGHT BE A LITTLE LESS
CONFUSION ON THAT BECAUSE IT'S
THAT WERE SIMPLY ADDING NEW
FUNCTION TO AN EXISTING
DEPARTMENT. SO THAT'S WHY IT'S
NOT GONE THROUGH THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION WE DON'T FEEL
THAT IT IS THAT WE ARE IF WE
THINK IT'S AN ADDITION OF MORE
STAFF TO ENHANCE EXISTING
THINGS AND DO PROTECTION THAT'S
NEEDED NOW AND IS A FEW MEMBERS
OF SAID. THERE IS SOME RAMP UP
SOME LEAD TIME TO HIRING INTO
STEPPING UP INTO DOING
REGULATIONS BUT IF WE DON'T
START NOW THEN IT ONLY FURTHERS.
THE POINT WITH WHICH WE CAN
ACTUALLY HELP CONSUMERS SO WE
WOULD LIKE YOU TO. FACTOR THAT
INTO YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WITH THAT WE'LL OPEN IT UP TO-
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL MOVE NOW TO
ANYONE WAITING. ONCE PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT- AGAIN AS I
STATED EARLIER DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS. I'M GOING TO
INSTITUTE A ONE MINUTE LIMIT ON
TESTIMONY BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT I KNOW THAT ARE
IN THE QUEUE- WE'RE GOING TO
ASK EVERYONE TO KEEP THEIR
REMARKS WITHIN ONE MINUTE- AND
THEY CAN BE ESTá SYNC THERE'S
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ACTIONS OR
NOT. LET'S BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY SEEN NONE
ANY WITNESSES IN HEARING ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SEEN NONE GREAT-
WILL MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR. IF YOU'D PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
COMMENT ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT PROPOSAL ONE
MINUTE EACH. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE AND
THEN ZERO WILL GO TO THE LINE
OF A ONE OH EIGHT. TWENTY ONE
OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BERMAN BONTA LINE OF ONE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CAT TAYLOR
I AM THE CO FOUNDER BOARD CHAIR
AND FORMER CEO OF BENEFICIAL
STATE BANK A COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION WITH BRANCHES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA OREGON AND
WASHINGTON. AND IT IS A STATE
BANK PROVIDING SMALL BUSINESSES
AND NONPROFITS BUT NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
LOANS SUPPORTING OVER EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND TRULY SMALL BUSINESS
EMPLOYEES OF THE- AND IT'S LED
BY WOMEN OR MINORITIES. I'M
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A
STRONG CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
FINANCIAL SERVICE REGULATOR. IN
JULY FOR THE FIFTH CONSECUTIVE
MONTH CONSUMER COMPLAINT TO THE
FEDERAL CFPB SEVEN NEW MONTHLY
COMPLAINT VOLUME RECORDS BUT
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF CREDIT
REPORTING TO PLAY THIRTEEN
RIGHT EIGHTY SIX PERCENT. THE
KICKER IN THE SKYROCKETING
COMPLAINT HOW MANY TIMES WHERE
THE CFPB'S ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
HAVE DROPPED BY THIRTY FIVE
PERCENT. AS A CRISIS WORSENS
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY THOSE BLACK BROWN
YOUNG NEW AND SENIOR CONSUMERS
ORGANIZATIONS. ACTIVELY
TARGETED BY BAD ACTORS WILL BE
IN DESPERATE NEED OF THE FBI
AND THE STATE COVERS WILL BE
STRESSED EVEN MORE AT NEW
COHORTS FALL INTO THE NEED FOR
ANTI POVERTY PROGRAMS WAITING
WILL JETTISON ACTUALLY WENT ON
ALL. THAT WE WILL DEEPLY REGRET
IN HINDSIGHT YOU MAY HEAR TODAY
FROM OTHER INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS THE FALSE
NARRATIVE THAT THE PROPOSED CBO
REVAMP ONLY CREATES A MORE
COMPLEX REGULATORY SCHEME THE
DISADVANTAGES BANKS. AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS RUN A BANK FOR OVER A
DECADE CO FOUNDED ON THE EVE OF
THE GREAT RECESSION. GOOD THANK
BANKS AND FINANCIAL SERVICES
SHOULD WELCOME THE PROPOSED THE
FBI WITH ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY
TO RESOURCES WHEN PREDATORY
PRACTICES AND PRODUCT DELIVERY%
TO MARKET. OFFERING AUDIBLE ONE
STRUGGLE TO COMPETE THIS IN
TURN UNDERMINES THE STABILITY
OF COMMUNITIES SMALL BUSINESSES
THE FINANCIAL INDUSTRY AND OUR
ECONOMY AS A WHOLE PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS. PROPOSAL. TO
ESTABLISH THAT THE FBI. I COULD
ADDITIONAL TO. MESSAGE WE NEED
YOUR LEADER AND- TO PROTECT
CONTENT. IN CALIFORNIA AT LAW.
AGAINST PREDATORY FINANCIAL
NGUYEN AND OTHERS. THAT LEAD TO
YOUR A- TIME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS FOR
ONE MAY. WHAT ALIGN THE ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHELIN BRADFORD ALEX OR THE
TRAGEDY THREE SIXTY ON WE HAVE
GOT SO A SAN FRANCISCO
HEADQUARTERED COMPANY THAT DOES
BENEFIT. THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
CLIENTS IN THE STATE WITH 90%
72% OF THE CLIENT. FIFTEEN
EMPLOYEES ARE LESS. I LEAST IT
DOES THIS OR WE HEARD
LEGISLATURE TO STRONG CONSIDER
THE ISSUE ACCESS FINANCIAL
MARKETS BURGER UNDERSERVED OR-
COMMUNITIES. THE NEW. HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY ENGAGE TRONG AND
FORCE BACK TO HELP PREVENT
APPLICATION IT ALSO HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE
INNOVATIVE NEW PATHWAYS. WITH
APPROPRIATE GUARDRAILS FOR
CERTIFIED IF YOU ARE THE ON AND
UNDERSERVED THE CHANCE TO OVER
THE- OPTED. INHIBITING THEIR
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
ECONOMY THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT THANK. YOU NEXT WITNESS
ONE MINUTE. WHAT ALIGN A ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO. SHARES AND
ROBERT WILL WITH CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION THE APPRECIATE THE
OP TO OFFER PREDICT. WE JUST
LIKE TO START BY SAYING RELY ON
COMMENTS MY CALL FROM C. B. A.
IS QUITE AS WE HEAVILY. AND
HAVE A. ARE ARE YOU BY BANKS A
PRE THE ALL. DOT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THE COMMISSION. AND
WE DID ASK THAT THIS. BILL MOVE
FORWARD OF ON THOSE THAT ARE ON
RIGHT AND LYFT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WHAT. ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU TO LOCAL NEXT DOOR OF
TWO ONE. PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MATT CHAIR TO JOHN
MOFFETT BEHALF OF THE K. FIND
SIR PROVIDER THIS IS WE AGREE
THE L. A. L. AND MEMBERS TODAY
WE NOT SUPPORT. AS CURRY
DRAFTED A IS BRETT BRETT AND
SING LACK OF D. OR CAN. THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY CANNOT
COMPLY WITH THAT WHICH WE
DECIPHER YOU KNOW WHEN IS THE
COVER PERSON WHAT IS THIS
PROVIDER IS I'M SURE JUST CHECK
OR ACTS TODAY COMMISSION STATE
THAT YOU THAT THE STATE THAT
WOULD BE REALLY AND SO. A ON
HOLD TAX NOT WHAT THE BOOK AND
OF YOU IN ADDITION WE THIS IS A
C. GRANTED AUTHORITY TO BLOOD.
TO THIS NEW BODY A STATE
SIGNIFICANT ROBUST REVIEW. BY
LEAD WE LEAVE THIS THIS RECORD
THE LEAD GIVING DECISION FOR
WORK TO MAY IT SO. THAT IT
SHOULD RETAIN FOR AT. AGAIN IS
CURRENTLY DRAFT WE ARE TO THE
DISTRICT THANK THANK YOU MUCH
NO WITNESS PLEASE ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU WHAT LINE UP ONE
THIRTY ONE. GET OUT CHAIR OF
THE AND BRAD. ROBERT HER WELL
EITHER TO OF THE FEDERAL OF
CALIFORNIA. FIRST A COMMENT
TEACHER MITCHELL I KNOW YOU A
VERY LONG DAY A LONG. WE REALLY
ARE. BY YOUR FORTY AND ON WAY
THAT YOU MONITOR AND THESE
HEARINGS THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M
PART OF THE BOOK. CONSUMER AND
MEDIUM SIZE IN THE COALITION
THAT IS SUPPORT THIS FOR AND
STRONG RESPONSE. ON THE IT
FIRST CAME OUT IN JANUARY AND
SO A NUMBER OF ISSUES HAVE BEEN
CLARIFIED AND CLEANED UP. I
THINK COMMITTEE SHOULD SHOULD
REALIZE THAT BOTH IMPROVE HAVE
BEEN TOGETHER ANCHOR. THE
SENATE LOOK AT RISK OF THAT
THERE CALL THE MESSAGE ABOUT TO
THE DOOR THE LACK TIME IF
YOU'VE GOT THE TRAILER BILL
THAT'LL- FOR IMMEDIATE ACTION
BY TO DEAL SOME OF THE THAT
RIGHT NOW THE CANNOT RESPOND TO
THEN YOU WILL NEED CAN TO SEE A
BETTER THANK OF WHAT'S AND
MARKET AND THEM THE GAPS RIGHT
AWAY WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
ONE MIN. OKAY SO I KNOW ONE OH
NINE PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MAY NUCLEAR AARON THE
DIRECTOR OF LIVING AND OUR
PUBLIC CENTER WHICH NONPROFIT
LEGAL ARE. IN ORANGE COUNTY BUT
THIS IS OKAY LOCK IN THAT
COLLECTION PREDATORY AND JACK.
YEAH I. WOULD ALLOW THE AGENCY
TO HAVE BROADER AND MORE
FLEXIBLE ENFORCEMENT AND
REGULATORY AUTHORITY WITH IN
CALIFORNIA. THE NEW DVO DOES
NOW. THAT WHEN CONSUMERS WILL
BE PROTECTED FROM UNLAWFUL
CREDIT CARD CHARGES PREDATORY
LOANS AND IN PARTICULAR THAT
COLLECTORS. SPECIALLY THOSE
THAT THE FEDERAL AGENCY CANNOT
COVER. CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
NEED TO BE AT THE AYE TO ENSURE
THAT AN AGENCY WITH THE ABILITY
TO STOP THE BAD ACTORS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
WHAT'S THE LINE OF ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TO BRING HIM ON BEHALF OF THE
FOR EXAMPLE YOU ARE TO. WHERE
TO CREATE. FINANCIAL SECURITY.
A LONG COMPETING FOR THE
VIBRANT OF INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE SHOULD WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE- LOCAL. NUMBER
ONE WHY TO BUY EVERY RETURN TO
THE- BECAUSE OF FINANCIAL
INSECURITY ON TOP OF THAT. 99%
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES
ECONOMIC ISSUES THE KURDS THE
LACK OF A LOT ABOUT HOW. TO USE
THE- A LACK OF THE HARM YOUR.
RIGHT HANDER LACK OF LOS HAVE A
LOT DOER. AND THE SYSTEMS YOU
NEED TO THEIR POWER AND CONTROL
SO. ON AB BY TITLE NEARLY SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR WORKING
FRAUDULENT DUTCH BECAUSE THE
HARM WORK. WE NEED THAT HASN'T
TO LOOK DEEP AND CREATING AN
NECESSARY AND OVERSIGHT TO
PROTECT COULD DO AND WORKING
FINANCIAL ACT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE.
WHAT ABOUT WHAT ABOUT THE LINE
OF A ONE OH THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH GOOD AFTERNOON CHILD
I'M STEPHANIE CAL FROM PUBLIC
COUNCIL THE LARGEST PROGRAMS I
WILL PUT IN THE COUNTRY AND WE
ARE IN FULL. I THINK MY
CONSUMER RIGHTS HE DELUGED WITH
HUNDREDS OF CASES RELATED TO
HATE FINANCING IT TOOK ME A TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO ACT. DESPITE
CHANGEABLE WITH SEEING CASE
MORE GRACIOUS OF THE FULL
CREDIT YOU FRANKLIN CONTINUE TO
DESTROY INTERGENERATIONAL
WEALTH IN A LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY THOSE OF
COLOR. THE FBI NEED EXTRACTABLE.
RESISTING LICENSEE. RENOVATE
AMERICA MAY ARGUE THAT THEY ARE
NOT VIOLATING PACIFIC STATUTE
WHEN THEY ALLOW SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR LEAD TO FISCAL
HAS WHEN YOU KNOW HOW DESPERATE
WHAT WAS THAT ADULTS. BUT
ESSENTIALLY ACTING UNFAIRLY WE.
HAVE A FLEET SUCH CASES.
HEATEDLY TO ENGAGE BY OF THE
MENU. BUT CONCERT SO WILL
PROVIDE DIRECT. PROJECT AND
THAT THAT ONE WITH THE-
MEANWHILE A CLIENT SITE EVERY
NEED TO THE COPAY. PUBLIC
HEALTH WHOLEHEARTEDLY FOR. OF
TO GET. PLEASE ALLOW THE FBI TO
FOR. AND PROVIDE PROTECTION FOR
CLIENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS ONE
MINUTE. ABOUT ONE OF ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A MAN AND
MISTER CHAIR OF THE- RAINY
COLLEGE BE HAVE BECAUSE DATA
INDUSTRY SO. CTIA IS WE
CONCERNED THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
COVERAGE OF CONSUMER REPORTING
ACTIVITIES ISN'T CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERAL LAW. REPORTING ACT
BOTH IN SCOPE AND SUBSTANCE WE
HAVE SHARED OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE VIDEO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THE RESPONSE THAT WE RECEIVED
FROM THEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SHARE THE MEMBERS
DOWN MARTIN YEAH WITH CONSUMER
REPORTS HELLO WE HAVE WORKED ON
THIS EFFORT WITH STAKEHOLDERS
FOR MANY MONTHS UNTIL THE IN
MANY YEARS- BUT BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS THE TIME- NOW IT'S
NEVER BEEN A BETTER TIME BUT IN
FACT MUST ACT NOW. INVEST IN A
IN A REVAMPED- ENDED IN A
REINTEGRATION OF THE CURRENT
DEPARTMENT AS THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL REGULATORS ARE YOU
SURE THAT WE ARE. NOW FOR WHAT
COULD BE EVEN A WORSENING
DOWNTURN AS THE CAN DOWN NEXT I
CANNOT ACCOUNT AS WELL AS QUITE
FRANKLY JUST THE WAY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PLAYS
LEAVING CONSUMERS SMALL
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES ARE
PAYING OFF A CLIFF- THIS IS NOT
IT'S NOT EXAGGERATION YEAH TWO
WEEKS LEFT CONGRESS HAS ALREADY
LEFT WITHOUT GIVING A COLD IT.
IS HELLO AND FUTURE IS VERY
UNCERTAIN BUT WHAT IS NEED
TODAY WHAT WE'VE ALREADY HEARD
PARTICULARLY FROM DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO CAN SPEAK
TO THE LIVED EXPERIENCES OF
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY OR ONE
CHECK AWAY FROM FALLING DOWN
INTO POVERTY OR WHO ARE TRYING
TO EXTRICATE THEMSELVES FROM
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS IN AN
ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS PEOPLE
NEED GOVERNMENT TO WORK THEY
NEED TO HAVE. CLEAR AUTHORITY
AND RESOURCES AT THESE KEY
INSTITUTIONS LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT THE DEPARTMENT CAN DO
THE WORK WONDERFUL RISKS WORK
WHEREVER POSSIBLE BENTALL LEARN
AND IF NEED BE IF SOMEONE'S
REALLY VIOLATING THE LAW TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE ACTION. THE JUNGLE
CANNOT DO THIS ON THEIR OWN
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO SEE IF YOU
CAN NOT DO THAT ON THEIR OWN
THEY'RE JUST LAW ENFORCEMENT WE
NEED A STRONG REGULATOR WITH
CLEAR CONSISTENT TOOL ADEQUATE
RESOURCES WHICH ARE
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT THE CURRENT
DEPARTMENT OF ALL THE WONDERFUL
WORK OF THE STOCK DOES NOT HAVE.
RIGHT NOW. TREINTA CONSUMER
ADVOCACY PROJECTS ADJUSTED
NUMBERS HE TURNED AREN'T THAT
YEAH COUNT. BECAUSE I DO NOT
LOOKED AT INCH THE DOMINANTLY
INCOME. TAKING A LOOK OF JACK
ACROSS. MANY OF WHOM ARE
MODELING. I TWENTY LIGHTING AND
ACTUALLY YORK RIGHT. THE COSBY
NINETY BACK IN. ARE INDUSTRY
FOR MANY OF OUR CLIENTS ARE.
OUR IS OFFERING. MAJORITY TO
COME. ADDITIONALLY IN THE LAST
NINE YOU MORE MODERATE
INCOMPLETE LOOKING HELP. WHAT
THE PEOPLE. WHO REALLY INCOME
AND I CAN. TO GET THE LETTER TO
PAGE WAY LONG JUST TO GET.
COUNTRY SENTENCES CULTURES. THE
NEED FOR ASKING CASH MEASURE
AND THE OUTCOME OF THE PROBLEM.
IS IN FACT MATTER I IT DALY.
THINGS ARE GOING TO GET WORSE
IN CALIFORNIA ARE GREATER. CASH
SCHLIEREN REPORT THE CAPTIVITY.
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. AND HOW TO ENACT
A MOAT IF. BILL POSSIBLE
FIGURES ONE THING CERTAIN. IN
SIXTEEN. OR A YEAR. WHAT IS A
DATASTAGE ECHO. CRISIS EVERY
SENATOR IN THIS ROOM IT'S GOING
TO BE GETTING BECAUSE- FROM.
CONCERT WHO GOT TO GET YOU ON I
CANNOT AFFORD BACK. IS
CONSIDERED ARE GOING TO BE
FAKING. WHAT TRANSACTION OR LAW.
AND THEY'RE GONNA THIS FOR HELP.
WE CAN CLEAN A ROBUST. AGENCIES
A FULL. OF PETITIONS CAR IN THE
TRAIL BILL. THE FLEXIBLE. OF
AUTHORITY GET LIGHT. WELLS
FARGO MAIN HELD BY. SPECIFIC
STATUTE WHEN IT OPEN PHANTOM
ACCOUNTS FOR MILLION OF
CUSTOMERS BUT IT DE. ACTED ON.
IF WE DO THAT. THE MEMBERS OF
THIS WILL BE TO TELL TEST FOR
CONSTRUED. YET CALLED THE- WE
SAW THIS CAR. COMING I MEAN
SURE TO CREATE ENGAGE. THAT
HELP YOU. ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE I MEAN YOUR
PHONE. GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS
FORMAL BURNED. BERMAN BONTA
LINE AT ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM SPEAKER MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS IT'S MIKE
BELOW OUR FIRM HAS A VARIETY OF
CLIENTS IN WHAT I SEE ARE THE
THREE MAIN CATEGORIES THAT IS
THE UNLICENSED. THE ENTITIES
LICENSED BY ANOTHER- REGULATOR
IN THE STATE AND THE ENTITIES
LICENSED BY DVO AND IT'S SORT
OF A GOOD NEWS BAD NEWS
SITUATION THE GOOD NEWS IS THE
COMMISSIONER AND HIS STAFF HAVE
BEEN VERY VERY GRACIOUS AND
GENEROUS AND ENGAGING WITH US.
TO DISCUSS THE PROPOSAL THE BAD
NEWS IS WE DON'T HAVE ANY MORE
CLARITY AFTER MANY MONTHS OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHO'S COVERED
AND WHO ISN'T IT'S SORT OF THE-
ALONG THE LINES OF DOCTOR PLANS
QUESTIONS- THE CALIFORNIA NEW
CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION FOR
EXAMPLE HAS MEMBERS WHO ARE
LICENSED BY THE- DMV AND THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
WE'VE ASKED ARE THEY- ARE THEY
PROVIDING A FINANCIAL SERVICE
SUCH THAT THEY WOULD NEED TO BE
A REGISTRANT. WE WERE TOLD
MOSTLY NOT WELL THEY ARE EXEMPT
UNDER DODD FRANK AND SO WE ARE
ASKING FOR CLARITY THAT THE
SAME EXEMPTION APPLIES HERE. WE
ALSO HAVE HAVE SIMILAR TO
LESCOTT GOVERNOR CLIENTS WHO
ARE UNLICENSED BUT WHOSE
ACTIVITIES ARE STRICTLY
REGULATED BY EXISTING
CALIFORNIA STATUTES FOR EXAMPLE
FORECLOSURE TRUSTEES STRICTLY
REGULATED BY THE CIVIL CODE
EVERYTHING THEY DO MUST COMPLY
WITH THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CIVIL CODE I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THEY ARE. A FINANCIAL SERVICE
PROVIDER OR NOT SO THERE NEEDS
TO BE WORKED OUT A LOT MORE
WORK IN OUR VIEW TO PROVIDE
CLARITY ON WHO'S COVERED AND
WHO'S LISTENING AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK. YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU WILL GO NEXT
LINE OF ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ALLISON KELLY AND I'M
THE CEO I. WE ARE BASED IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA IN THE
NINETEEN NINETY GARY EVERY.
YOUR MENTORSHIP. THE RACIAL AND
GENDER WELL YEAH. CONSUMERS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE SUFFERING
FROM COLD AND- THE LENDING
GROUP ARE COUNTING ON THEIR OWN
ABILITY. SMALL BUSINESSES NO
FEDERAL PROTECTION EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT OUR COMMUNITY CANNOT WAIT
ANOTHER YEAR ESPECIALLY NOT
NOW. YEAH I SUPPORT. OKAY WELL
THAT THE ONLY. ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
COMMENT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU A LOT FIND ONE SEVEN
YOU KNOW LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH GOOD AFTERNOON SHARES
BRADFORD AND MITCHELL THIS IS
LEON TRODDEN ON BEHALF AT THE
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND NOT STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL. WE COMMEND THE
GOVERNOR AND THE DEPARTMENT FOR
THEIR VISION AND WORKING TO
BUILD THE EXISTING DEPARTMENT
ENJOYS STRONG ADEQUATELY
RESTORED CONSUMER FINAL
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AGENCY.
THE CURRENT ECONOMIC CRISIS
PRESENT URGENCY TO THE PROPOSED
REFORM AND VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS CAN ILL AFFORD TO
WAIT ANOTHER YEAR. WE NOW
FINANCIAL CRISES GREAT
PREDATORY FINANCIAL PRACTICES
AND THE EXISTING MENTORS THAT
SIMPLY DO NOT PERMIT NEEDED
WROTE BACK AND FORTH THAT. ON
PROTECTION IN THE PROPOSAL
SHOULD NOT BE COMPROMISED
CARIBBEAN LICENSEES OUT CREATED
PATCHWORK SYSTEM OF COURSE
MINUTES ALREADY THIS IS A
NIGHTMARE FOR REGULATORS AND
NIGHTMARE FOR CONSUMERS AND A
NIGHTMARE FOR THE ADVOCATE TO
FIGHT TO PROTECT THEM ANY
COMPLAINT. ENCOURAGES GOOD
BUSINESS PRACTICES PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE SIXTEEN.
HI MY NAME IS LOUIS GETS BACK
AND THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY PREVENTING CLUB LARGEST
MARKETPLACE LENDING CAN CHECK
COMPANY OUT WE CONSULTED OTHER
THIRTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
FINANCING TO CONSUMERS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES- OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION CUSTOMERS AND
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL- PROVIDED INCLUDES
SPECIAL PROTECTIONS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. AS A MEMBER OF THE
INDUSTRY WE REALLY WANT TO ECHO
THAT COMMISSIONERS CALLS AND
THE COMMENTS SO MANY OTHERS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD IT'S BAD
FOR OUR CUSTOMERS BADGERED
SMALL BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS-
THAT IS BAD PRESERVATION AND
DEVELOPMENT GOOD PRODUCTS FOR
RESPONSIBLE COMPANIES HAVE TO
COMPETE. AGAINST BAD ACTORS
THAT FIND IT THEY ENGAGE IN
UNFAIR OR DECEPTIVE ACTS- I
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE YOU
ARE A RECENT HEADLINE IN NBC
NEWS LEGAL LOAN SHARKS MAY BE
EXPLOITING CORONAVIRUSES HE'S
SMALL BUSINESSES- THAT
BEGINNING DOWN TO A QUESTION
ABOUT HOW LONG THE MEDICATION
WILL WILL. H. THIS IS GOING TO
GO ON FOR A LONG TIME WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING OUT OF THIS FOR
A LONG TIME THAT WE CAN
QUESTION A- WHAT WILL RECOVERY
LOOK LIKE HOW MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES WILL BE LEFT. TEN
SECONDS AGAIN. AND SO I YOUR
SUPPORT FOR EIGHT FOUR A TREE
BILL. THAT WHO SCORED WITH.
EXPLICIT AND GOLD. FOR SMALL AS
WELL. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS OUT ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
WELL I HAVE ONE THIRTY FOUR
CLICK OR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DANIEL COUNTERCULTURE WITH
CORBIN KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW CENTER.
AN ORGANIZATION THAT WORK
TOWARD ECONOMIC JUSTICE
INCLUDED NINETEEN CRISIS HAS
MADE CONSUMER PROTECTION A
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S STAGGERING
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AND CONSUMER
DEBT MOUNTING EVERY DAY.
CALIFORNIANS ARE FACING AN
ALMOST FUNDS AND ALMOST CERTAIN
INCREASE IN DEBT COLLECTION OF
PREDATORY FINANCIAL PRODUCTS IN
THE COMING YEARS. MORE THAN
EVER. CONSUMER PROTECTION WILL
PROVIDE AN ESSENTIAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND RECOVERY TOOLS
THAT WERE WILL HELP KEEP
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR HOMES IN
THEIR CARS. AND ABLE TO RETURN
TO WORK AS WELL AS THE ABILITY
TO INVEST THEIR PAGES IN THEIR
LOCAL BUSINESSES AND
COMMUNITIES. NCL PAPERS WITH
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT THEIR
CONSTITUENTS IN THESE UNCERTAIN
TIMES. AND TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE PROTECTIONS THIS PROPOSAL
WILL PROVIDE. WILL BE ONGOING
AND ESSENTIAL. WE URGE YOU ALL
TO VOTE FOR THE FBI PROPOSAL AS
IT COMES BEFORE YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUT MODERATE REFER
YOU OVER THE NEXT LINE IF I
COULD JUST ASK FOLKS LIKE WE
DID EARLIER YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION WHAT DO YOU
SUPPORT OR DON'T SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL IF THERE IS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO SHARE PLEASE BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY IF YOU SUPPORT.
OR DON'T SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
AT THIS POINT AT FIVE TO FOUR
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED HERE TO TRY
TO GET AS MANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
AS POSSIBLE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NINE ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AARON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS PAT HELLO I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION WHOSE MEMBERSHIP
MAKES UP A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT MORTGAGE RELATED
LICENSE EACH WE RESPECTFULLY
HAVE REAL CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL'S POTENTIAL IMPACT
GIVEN THE ABSENCE OF THE
SHOWING THAT THERE'S A
DEFICIENCY IN OUR EXISTING
LICENSING STRUCTURE. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES WITH LICENSE
LENDERS AND SERVICERS ARE
WORKING HARD TO HELP OUR IS
EXPERIENCING PUBLIC RELATED
FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES WE
BELIEVE THAT THE PROBLEM
PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD YOU
SHOULD FOCUS ON REGULATED
ENTITIES AND NOT ON THE CARPET
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT LICENSEES
THAT ALREADY HAVE A ROBUST.
REGULATORY STRUCTURE THANK. YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THE
MEMBERS OF THE CANADIAN THANK
YOU CARE ACT THAT CAN BE FOR
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS DURING
THAT TIME NAME IS BIANCA
MANAGED THE OPERATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR A SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY FOR A NONPROFIT
RESEARCH ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION
ORGANIZATION. FOUNDED AND RUN
BY SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS. OUR
BUSINESS A GREAT AMERICANS
SECTOR WORKFORCE. NINETY THREE
FINANCIAL HABITS ON OUR NATION
BOTH NUMEROUS EMPLOYERS. WHAT
MARK MOTHER'S NAKED IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE NO FEDERAL
PROTECTION FROM THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU.
OUR BUSINESSES ANALYZING THAT
THE TIMELINE AND DESERVE THE
PROTECTION OF THE FPI FULLY AND
EXPLICITLY THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS.
GESTUURD NAME AN ORGANISED IN
YOUR POSITION PLEASE. ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WILL MOVE ON TO ONE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OLD NAME MY
NAME IS BEING A DOCTOR I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE OTHER LINE AT
THE GATE I'M CALLING IT IS.
CALLING IN TO SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NUMBER NINE ONE NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELL I'M CLOUDY
FOUNDER AND THE INVEST IN WOMEN
ENTREPRENEURS IN THE HEAD AND
WE WORK TO RAISE SUBSTANTIAL
NEW FUNDING FOR WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS AND THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SERVE THEM I'M CALLING
TODAY IS THE COURTS TO TRAILER
BILL AND I WANT TO POINT OUT
PARTICULARLY THE DATA FROM THE
FEDERAL RESERVE LAST YEAR
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. SHOWED
THAT 32% LONG BUSINESSES WERE
USING UNREGULATED. ONLINE
LENDER. GEN WHERE WE ARE NOW
AND WE- FROM OUR AND- THAT HE
ARE PRETTY DARN. WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED IT. BEING SERVED
BY REGULATED BANKS FINANCIAL
SERVICES. I URGE YOU TO TRAILER
BILL COVERAGE ALONG. RANGE
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
THE NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE TRAILER. NINE
ONE FORTY HE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHARLENE
MARTINEZ FROM KENYA THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR MY
CURRENT. STATEWIDE NETWORK OF
SMALL BUSINESS ADVISING
ORGANIZATIONS AND MISSION BASED
LENDERS WORKING UNDER A
MINORITY BUSINESS OWNERS TODAY
WE ARE TREATED TO SUPPORT OTHER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION
PROPOSAL THAT COVERS YOUR GOAL
BUSINESSES FULLY AND EXPLICITLY
BUT SEATED MALL BUSINESS THAT'S
SUFFERING THE IMPACT OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MANY YEARS
MALL BUSINESSES WE WORK REYES
ARE DEEPLY PRACTICED BY THE
CONSEQUENCES UPCOMING NINETEEN
CRISIS- PREDATORY LENDING ONLY
MAKE THE RECORDING CHALLENGES
TOWARDS THE MALL BUSINESSES
HAVE NO FEDERAL PROTECTION FROM
THE D. S. B. V. WHICH THEY NEED
THAT. COULD YOU COULD HEAR YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. POSITION THE TRAILER
BILL PLEASE. NINE ONE OH FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM AND SEND.
I WILL NOT FIND A CLINIC
TEACHING AT. CALIFORNIA IRVINE
CONSUMER LACHLAN AND WE AND
SUPPORT OF VIDEO. AND WARREN
HAD PENNED DIMMING AND BUT
RIGHT NOW. WELL MORE INCOME
HELP WILL VICTIM TO CREDIT
LENDER AND CLASS SCHMIDT YOU
ARE THIRD GOT IN THE UNITED
STATES POSTED RECORD PROFITS.
IN THE LAST QUARTER DURING THIS
CRISIS. ELECTING PEOPLE OF WORK
SECOND IN WERE COLLECT PAYMENTS
FROM STIMULUS JACKSON ON A
PLANE AND THEN AT THAT OKAY I'M
GONNA. CALL AN EMPHASIS IN INSUPPORT OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. STRONG WINDS IN
STRONG SUPPORT EXCELLENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS SIKI TAD AND THEN
DIRECTOR OF THE CONSUMER LAW
CLINIC A UC IRVINE AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THEMSELVES THANK YOU CAN TELL
THAT WE HAVE AND OKAY DO THAT
P. AND PLAYS JUST TAKING NAME
ORGANIZATION YOUR POSITION IF
YOU HAVE FULL STATEMENTS FEEL
FREE TO MAIL THEM IN TO THE
OFFICE WE'RE TRYING TO ADJOURN
AT FOUR O'CLOCK WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF CALLERS LAUGH FROM
ASKING FOR NAME. ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION IF YOU HAVE
WRITTEN STATEMENTS FEEL FREE TO
MAIL THE MAN MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. TWENTY ONE
FORTY NINE. YOUR CHAIR. AND
YOUR EMPLOYEE ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI HE
SIGNED A LETTER ALONG WITH THE
MAYORS OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
JOSE STOCKTON OAKLAND
SACRAMENTO AND LONG BEACH IN
SUPPORT OF THE FBI BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WHY NOT ONE FORTY SIX.
AB CAN KANA ONLINE LENDERS
ALLIANCE OPPOSED. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. ONE FORTY ONE HE-
TO ENSURE NUMBERS MANUALLY ON
BEHALF OF CARE OF FINANCIAL AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO DO
PROCESS AND SUBSTANCE I JUST
WANNA LINE OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL SERVICES PROVIDER THE
STATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. WHY NOT. ONE
FORTY FIVE. YEAH I MEAN THE
ADDED ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR ABOUT HOW WE NEED A MOMENT
CORPORATION AND IN TERMS OF THE
PROPOSAL. THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HERE FROM ALREADY WELL LAST
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY WE THERE
ARE MODERATE SOMEBODY ON COUNTY
WE WORK- BY FORTY WOMEN
MINORITY IMMIGRANT AND RON
MICHAEL IS MONITORED. OR THE
START. AND THAT COULD BE AFTER
CORNER FIVE MILLION COMMUNITY.
THEY'RE READY TO THAT WE ARE
HAVE BEEN UNDER A- CREDIT
RATING. THE MARTIN SMALL. ARE
OPERATING ON CARBON NINETEEN
THANK YOU MUCH AND YOU JUST GO
US A ON TRAILER BILL YOUR OF
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. AS STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL EXCELLENT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. RIGHT ONE
TWENTY THREE. LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE. I IS THAT MY LINE YEAH
YES THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS
NANCY I'M THE REPRESENTATIVE OF
TO STATEWIDE COALITION ONE OF
SB A DESIGNATED WOMEN BUSINESS
AND HAVING MANY MANY CRIMES WE
HAVE DESCRIBED HERE- THEY CAN
PUT IT TO A LANDING AND ALSO
I'VE BEEN MOVING CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEER INCOME TAX ASSISTANCE
SITES THAT SERVE LOW INCOME
TAXPAYERS I AM IN JOHN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. AND THAT COVERS
ALL BUSINESS FULLY AND
EXPLICITLY THANK YOU DEAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
POSITION. ON BILL AND NAME.
WHEN. ONE FIFTY FOUR. MY NAME
IS MARGARET WELL I'VE SEEN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BANKING
NETWORK WE APPRECIATE THE
IMPORTANCE ONE NEXT MORE
CONTESTS WE CONCUR WITH MR
GOULD'S. COMMENTS THEY HAVE
NUMEROUS OTHER CLIENT YOU MAY
HAVE TO REGISTER I CONCUR WITH
THE CHURCH GOVERNOR'S COMMENTS
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE CLARITY.
THERE WILL NOT BE DUPLICATIVE
FORTUNATELY HAD KIND OF A PARTY
DEALERS COVERED PERSONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
ONE FIFTY FIVE. BARTOLO WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. AND THAT CHAIRPERSON
OF THE STEERING COMMITTEE THAT
AT THAT THE CALLED IN SUPPORT
OF THE TRAVEL LANGUAGE THANK
YOUTHANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE ONE FIFTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
DRIVING LITTLE COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT A PROPOSAL
THAT TRAINING INSTITUTE IN
COLLEGE MORE BUSINESSES AS WELL
AS CONTINUOUS THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE FIFTY TWO.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE FIFTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
OF THE SIRENS BY THE CEO OF
WORKING SOLUTIONS VERY
NONPROFIT CDFI. THIRTY NINE
COUNTY BAY AREA. STRONG SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE FIFTY NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEREMIAH FROM
THE SENATE LEGAL SERVICES IN
LOS ANGELES WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
REASONS EXPRESSED BY OUR LEGAL
SERVICES PARTNERS AND I
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. NO FURTHER WITNESSES
THANK YOU. THAT'S WHAT E WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THOSE WHO
CALLED IN TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PUBLIC COMMENT COMPONENT OF
TODAY'S HEARING. THE. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU WHO
PARTICIPATED ON BOTH PUBLIC
COMMENT AND OUR PANELISTS WHO
WERE ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
AGAIN IF THEY'RE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT WHO HAD A
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER PLEASE FEEL FREE- TO
SEND THEM TO THE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE- OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FORGIVEN
OF YOUR SATURDAY WE'VE
CONCLUDED TODAY'S AGENDA AND
THIS AFTERNOON'S HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.